la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribuée il n'y a pas d'observation le
procès-verballé est adopté sous les
réserves d'usage
l'ordre du jour appelle la désignation
des 19 membres de la commission
d'enquête sur l'efficacité des
politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique en application de
l'article 8 ter alinéa 5 de notre
règlement les listes des candidats
présentés par les groupes ont été
publiés ces candidatures seront
ratifiées si la présidence ne reçoit pas
d'opposition dans le délai d'une heure
prévue par notre règlement
alors l'ordre du jour rappelle la
désignation des 23 membres de la mission
d'information sur le thème le
développement d'une filière de
biocarburant carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert en application
de l'article 8 du règlement les listes
des candidats remises par les groupes
politiques ont été publiés ces
candidatures seront ratifiées s'il n'y a
pas d'opposition dans le délai d'une
heure prévue par notre règlement
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi relative à l'accélération
des procédures liées à la construction
de nouvelles installations nucléaires à
proximité de sites nucléaires existants
et au fonctionnement des installations
existantes la procédure accélérée a été
engagée sur ce texte
avant de passer à la discussion de ce
texte je vous informe qu'en accord avec
la Commission et le gouvernement nous
suspendrons nos travaux en fin
d'après-midi à 18h55 pour les reprendre
à 21h pour la cérémonie des vœux du
président Gérard Larcher
monsieur le Président
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à Madame Agnès panière une haché
ministre de la transition énergétique
c'est la parole même le ministre
madame la Présidente je salue aussi
monsieur le Président ce qu'on a la
chance d'en avoir plusieurs Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs madame et monsieur le
président de commission mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs après l'examen
du projet de loi d'urgence sur
l'accélérateur de la production
d'énergie renouvelable je poursuis la
feuille de route que je vous ai exposé
avec l'examen de ce projet de loi
d'urgence sur le nucléaire il est
important car il permettra d'accélérer
les procédures administratives de
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
électronucléaires dans notre pays avec
deux objectifs
raccourcir les délais de réalisation de
ces projets de plusieurs années et
contribuer à en baisser le coût pour les
consommateurs mais avant de rentrer plus
concrètement dans le contenu du texte je
souhaite évoquer le contexte dans lequel
il s'inscrit
ce contexte c'est d'abord celui de
l'urgence d'une crise climatique qui
menace nos écosystèmes nos sociétés et
l'avenir de nos enfants une crise qui
doit nous amener à atteindre la
neutralité carbone d'ici 2050
ce contact est aussi celui de la crise
énergétique que connaît l'Europe et une
grande partie du monde depuis l'année
dernière la guerre qui se déroule en ce
moment aux portes de l'Europe en Ukraine
remet profondément en cause notre
approvisionnement et fragilise notre
économie du fait du prix de l'énergie
des prix l'énergie qui se sont envolés
en 2022 ces deux crises ont une même
origine notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles pour à peu près deux tiers de
notre consommation finale d'énergie
qu'il s'agisse du gaz ou du pétrole et
de manière minoritaire du charbon c'est
la raison pour laquelle l'ambition du
président de la République et du
gouvernement mené par la première
ministre et de devenir le premier grand
pays industriel à sortir de sa
dépendance aux énergies fossiles c'est
un impératif climatique bien sûr mais
aussi un impératif pour le pouvoir
d'achat des Français pour la capacité
d'investissement de nos collectivités et
la compétitivité de nos entreprises à
long terme et plus profondément un
impératif pour notre indépendance
politique
notre stratégie pour sortir des énergies
fossiles reposent vous le savez bien sur
quatre grands et indissociables piliers
d'une part la réduction de la
consommation d'énergie avec la sobriété
et l'efficacité énergétique car si nous
voulons atteindre la neutralité carbone
l'objectif que nous assène lié que nous
assigne les experts notamment ceux de
RTE c'est de réduire de 40% notre
consommation d'énergie à horizon 2050 le
plan de sobriété que j'ai présenté de B
début octobre avec la première ministre
et la première brique de cette
trajectoire de long terme et il produit
déjà des effets importants dans tous les
secteurs de l'économie grâce à la
mobilisation des entreprises des
collectivités locales et des
administrations et plus largement grâce
à la mobilisation des Français que je
veux remercier ici
nous sommes de ce fait dans les
meilleures conditions pour passer cet
hiver mais surtout nous continuons à
diminuer nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre alors même que la crise ferrage
notre stratégie énergétique repose
d'autres parts sur l'augmentation
drastique et durable de notre production
d'énergie des carbonée sur ce point nous
n'avons pas le luxe de choix idéologique
l'enjeu n'est pas le nucléaire contre
les énergies renouvelables qui sont des
énergies bas carbone l'enjeu est celui
des énergies décarbonées contre les
énergies fossiles notre stratégie
implique d'abord d'accélérer autant que
possible la production d'énergie
renouvelable c'est l'enjeu des 15
prochaines années c'est l'objet du
projet de loi d'accélération que vous
avez voté à la quasi unanimité et qui
fera l'objet d'une commission mixte
paritaire la semaine prochaine
notre stratégie implique ensuite la
relance d'un programme nucléaire dans le
contexte d'un parc vieillissant ce sont
28 réacteurs qui arriveront à plus de 50
années d'exploitation d'ici 2035 vous le
savez le gouvernement fait le choix de
la relance de la construction de
réacteurs et la poursuite d'exploitation
des réacteurs en exercice aussi
longtemps que les enjeux de sûreté nous
le permettrons
dans le prolongement de l'orientation du
président de la République qui a EDF en
novembre 2018 de travailler à
l'élaboration d'un programme du nouveau
nucléaire et de ses déclarations du 10
février 2022 à Belfort le projet de loi
qui nous rassemble aujourd'hui marque
une nouvelle phase de notre politique
nucléaire en introduisant un cadre
d'accélération du processus
d'autorisation administrative pour les
futurs projets nucléaires je veux
vraiment insister sur ce point ce texte
ne vise pas à décider ni de la place de
l'énergie nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique français ni des détails d'un
programme de nouveaux nucléaires ni de
la politique en matière de traitement et
de recyclage des déchets ou de la R&D
d'autres textes le feront d'autres
textes l'ont déjà fait certaines
dispositions isolées ont été introduites
en commission la semaine dernière qui
concerne ses aspects de programmation
énergétique nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir pendant l'examen des amendements
mais vous le savez parfaitement ce n'est
pas un texte programmation énergétique
en effet
la loi de programmation énergétique doit
être précédée d'une grande concertation
sur l'avenir de notre mix énergétique
pour recueillir la vie des Français sur
cette prochaine loi qui sera soumise au
Parlement en 2023 cette concertation
utile est nécessaire à démarrer en
octobre dernier et totalisent plus de
25000 contributions à ce jour elle sera
conclue du 19 au 22 janvier 2023
c'est-à-dire d'ici la fin de cette
semaine par un forum des jeunesses
auquel d'ailleurs nous avons invité les
membres de la commission des affaires
économiques et les membres de la
commission Développement Durable qui
réunira 200 jeunes de 18 à 35 ans et son
résultat vous sera communiqué dans son
intégralité pour le débat parlementaire
sur la loi de programmation énergique
climat qui conduira mettre à jour la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
le présent texte et n'en n'est pas moi
très important en effet les dispositions
qui sont prévues dans ce texte prépare
l'avenir et sécurisent les délais de
décision que vous pouvez prendre dans
les délais dans les mois qui viennent
elles vont avoir un impact sur le délai
de mise en service et donc sur le coût
des éventuels futures nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires en France je veux également
être très clair vous n'allez pas
aujourd'hui acter un quelconque
affaiblissement des enjeux de sûreté
nucléaire de protection de la
biodiversité ou encore de participation
du public en votant ce texte le texte ne
modifie ni le processus d'autorisation
environnementale ni le processus
d'autorisation de création qui traite
des enjeux de sûreté nucléaires ces deux
autorisations demeurent tout aussi
rigoureuses qu'elle l'était par le passé
de la même manière que les deux enquêtes
publiques préalables ou encore que le
processus de débat public conduit en ce
moment sous l'égide de la Commission
Nationale pour la construction d'une
première pierre à penlit et qui se
terminera le 27 février Commission
nationale du débat public enfin il est
important de préciser ce cadre
d'accélération et borné dans le temps et
dans l'espace de manière à être
proportionnée et compatible avec
l'ambition qui a été proposé par le
Président de la République qui est de
construire si réacteurs dans un premier
temps de lancer les études pour 8 autres
il ne s'applique que pour les projets de
construction de réacteur nucléaires qui
sont localisés à proximité du périmètre
de site nucléaire existant et dont la
demande d'autorisation de création est
déposée dans les 20 ans qui suivent la
première négation de la présente loi 20
ans c'est le délai qui a été ajusté par
la commission lors de son examen enfin
ce texte ne préampe pas la technologie
des réacteurs et peut donc s'appliquer
tout aussi bien à des EPR KD petit
réacteurs des SMR et je sais que
beaucoup ici sont attachés à ce principe
d'ouverture de neutralité technologique
ces précisions étant apportées je tiens
maintenant à vous exposer brièvement ce
que fait ce projet de loi pour accélérer
les projets de construction nouveau
réacteurs nucléaires il commence par
rendre possible la mise en compatibilité
des documents locaux d'urbanisme en
effet les procédures existantes en
matière d'urbanisme sont incompatibles
avec la complexité d'un projet de
réacteurs électronucléaire et la
nécessité de les mettre à jour conduira
augmenter de plusieurs années la durée
de construction
il permet ensuite de garantir le
contrôle de la conformité au respect des
règles d'urbanisme tout en dispensant de
permis de construire les installations
et travaux portant sur la création d'un
réacteur électronucléaire et des
équipements et installations nécessaires
à son exploitation à compter de
l'obtention de la première autorisation
environnementale le texte permet de
mener en parallèle l'instruction de
l'autorisation de création et les
activités relatives aux constructions
aménagement installations et travaux
préalables en gros on ne perd pas de
temps ce texte vient également rendre
possible la construction de directeur
nucléaire à proximité des réacteurs
existant localisés en bord de mer c'est
d'importance puisque vous le savez les
deux premiers sites envisagés pour les
deux premières paires de réacteurs sont
ceux de Pandi et de Gravelines
au regard de l'intérêt particulier pour
la notion de ses projets nucléaires ce
texte prévoit des mesures de
sécurisation de l'accès aux fonciers
mobilisable en dernier recours et en cas
de blocage en s'inspirant de ce qui a
déjà été fait notamment ce qui existe
pour d'autres projets d'ampleur comme le
projet ITER au total ce texte permettra
de ne pas ajouter un délai de 2 à 3
années à la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs l'idée c'est que le temps de
construction du réacteur soit un temps
industriel et que les procédures
administratives soient réalisées en
temps masqué par rapport à ce temps
industriel dans le contexte dans lequel
nous sommes cela compte proposer un
cadre conciliant les impératifs
d'accélération et de sécurisation des
projets de nouveaux nucléaires tout en
conciliant les plus hautes exigences en
matière d'associations des partis
prenantes de protection de la
biodiversité de sécurité voilà
l'ambition de ce texte ce projet de loi
s'insère dans un ensemble de mesures
mises en oeuvre pour poser les rails
juridiques organisationnelles industriel
financier et procédureaux de la relance
d'une politique ambitieuse en matière de
nucléaire civil il est un maillon d'une
stratégie d'ensemble engagée depuis
plusieurs années pour construire notre
indépendance énergétique et mener la
bataille du climat en sortant de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles je
souhaite conclure en faisant 10 ans que
ce texte est aussi important qu'il est
technique l'enjeu sera donc d'éviter que
les petits grains de sable ne viennent
compliqués ralentir ou fragiliser
juridiquement des projets qui sont déjà
dans leur substance très complexes par
nature c'est pourquoi je défendrai
aujourd'hui des amendements qui
permettront de compléter le travail très
significatif et très complet mené par la
commission des affaires économiques et
par la commission d'aménagement
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable la semaine
dernière je tiens à les remercier pour
cela je remercie tout particulièrement
leur apporteur Daniel grimillier le
rapporteur pourra vivre Pascal Martin
ainsi que les présidents de commission
Sophie prima et Jean-François je vous
remercie merci Madame la Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Daniel grimiller
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques et pour 10 minutes chers
collègues
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président du Sénat madame la
président de la commission des Affaires
économique monsieur le Président de la
Commission des affaires de développement
durable chers collègues rapporteur pour
avis Pascal Martin mes chers collègues
en 1971 le président Georges Pompidou
s'est exprimait en ces termes au sujet
du premier plan nucléaire civil je cite
il nous appartient de concevoir une
politique de l'énergie politique
d'autant plus importante pour la France
que nos ressources propres sont modestes
nous avons décidé d'accélérer notre
programme d'utilisation de l'énergie
nucléaire considéré comme un facteur
important d'indépendance énergétique
50 ans plus tard ce constat n'a rien
perdu de son acuité oui l'énergie
nucléaire est centrale et oui une
politique énergétique est indispensable
or le projet de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui si le revalorise
utilement l'énergie nucléaire n'offre
aucune réponse s'agissant de notre
politique énergétique je veux le dire
solennellement ici la relance du
nucléaire ne peut se résumer à un texte
de simplification pour réussir il faut
une vision politique cohérente au-delà
des procédures techniques disparates
de plus le texte manque de perspective
de profondeur alors qu'il nous est
demandé de légiférer jusqu'en 2038 au
moins le nucléaire de demain ne sera pas
celui d'hier au-delà de notre
indépendance énergétique il contribuera
aussi à notre transition énergétique car
l'enjeu sera d'électrifier pour
décaporner afin d'atteindre la stratégie
carbone d'ici 2050 le nucléaire de
demain sera confronté à de nouveaux
risques climatiques et numérique nos
réacteurs devront être plus résilients
le nucléaire de demain sera plus divers
outre les epères de se développeront des
réacteurs de taille ou de technologie
différentes pour réduire les risques et
les déchets de même qu'un couplage entre
les productions d'électricité et
d'hydrogène
utile à l'industrie et au transport
enfin le nucléaire de demain s'inscrira
dans une nouvelle société une société
plus décentralisée où la voie des
collectivités et des citoyens portera
encore plus aux côtés de logiciel de
l'État une société plus exigeante aussi
où la sûreté des réacteurs et la gestion
des déchets devront être assurés au-delà
de la production c'est cette vision
résolument moderne de l'énergie
nucléaire fondée sur la science et la
raison inscrite dans le monde actuel
ouvert sur les technologies futures que
notre commission a souhaité porter car
seul à cette vision et à la hauteur des
grands défis économiques énergétiques le
nucléaire est notre
héritage et notre horizon sachant le
relancer en tenant compte de ce
changement d'époque
notre commission est très attachée à
l'énergie nucléaire nous l'avons
démontré dans nos travaux législatifs
avant et bien souvent contre le
gouvernement ça ne fut pas simple de
décaler de 10 ans le calendrier de
fermeture des réacteurs dans la loi
énergie climat de 2019 ça ne fut pas
simple non plus de conditionner tout
autre fermeture à la prise en compte son
impact sur notre sûreté notre
approvisionnement et nos émissions dans
la loi climat résilience de 2021 notre
commission a aussi démontré cette
attachement dans ces travaux de contrôle
la mission d'information transpartizane
conduite avec mes collègues Jean-Pierre
Moga et Jean-Jacques Michaud a ainsi
plaidé pour construire 14 EPR 2 et 4 GW
de SMR afin de maintenir de maintenir
d'un mixte majoritairement nucléaire
d'ici 2050 lors de mes travaux préalable
j'ai entendu une centaine de
personnalités au cours d'une
cinquantaine d'auditions je remercie
vivement leur rapporteurs pour avis
Pascal Martin des excellentes relations
de travail que nous avons loué elles
nous ont permis d'organiser des
auditions communes et de présenter des
rédactions communes cela confère au
Sénat une voie forte et unie sur ce
sujet essentiel je retiens de ces
travaux au préalable un large consensus
sur l'objectif du texte mais aussi de
Lourdes critiques sur la méthode
s'agissant de l'objectif le texte doit
permettre d'accélérer la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs d'une part certaines
procédures sont simplifiées notamment en
matière d'urbanisme de construction ou
d'expropriation d'autre part certains
axes sont réduits et élevés aux rang de
décret pour concentrer le contentieux
devant le Conseil d'État au total le
gain pourrait être de 56 mois pour EDF
concernant la méthode elle est
perfectible à plus d'un titre tout
d'abord le gouvernement légifère dans le
désordre car il aurait fallu
je m'excuse madame la ministre soumettre
à l'examen parlementaire le projet de
loi quincennale sur l'énergie pour que
celui sur nucléaire est enfin celui du
renouvelable on est complètement à
l'envers plus encore le gouvernement
légifère dans la précipitation le Sénat
ayant été informé mi-décembre de
l'examen du projet de loi sur les
nucléaires et de la tenue de la
commission mix paritaire sur le projet
de loi sur les énergies renouvelables ce
mois-ci autre difficulté le gouvernement
omet les consultations en cours la
Commission nationale du débat public
ayant été chargé du débat sur
l'évolution du mix énergétique et le
programme du nouveau nucléaire dont le
site de Pandi enfin le gouvernement se
focalise sur la simplification élu dans
les questions cruciales de la révision
de la planification énergétique de la
décision de construction des réacteurs
et des moyens financiers et humains
nécessaires avec en filigrane le devenir
de la régulation du nucléaire et du
groupe EDF
surtout
ce texte ne doit pas faire oublier la
responsabilité du gouvernement dans le
déclin de la filière du nucléaire
jusqu'en 2022 et le tournant du discours
de Belfort il a impliqué une politique
d'attrition du nucléaire existant et
d'indécision sur le nouveau nucléaire or
pour notre commission il faut renverser
la tendance il ne faut pas se limiter
aux annonces discours de Belfort mais
construit bien davantage de père de dans
ce contexte j'ai adopté une quarantaine
d'amendements en commission j'ai fait
adopté pardon une quarantaine
d'amendements commission afin de
compléter le texte selon quatre axes
majeurs le premier axe vise à en combler
les angles morts à cette fin j'ai
proposé d'allonger à 20 ans la durée des
mesures de simplification et d'y
intégrer aux côtés des EPR 2 les projets
de SMR et d'hydrogène j'ai aussi voulu
clarifier la notion de proximité
immédiate selon les préconisations de
l'Association des maires de France j'ai
prévu que l'État rentre au Parlement de
la mise en oeuvre des mesures et
chantiers afin d'être informé sans
omission des éventuels dépassements de
délai et de coûts il devra aussi nous
indiquer les six retenus par EDF une
clause de revoyure permettra d'inclure
de nouveaux sites et de nouvelles
technologies
de plus j'ai proposé de réviser la
planification énergétique enlevant les
verrous issus de la loi de transition
énergétique de 2015 il faut approcher
l'objectif de réduction à 50% de
l'énergie nucléaire d'ici 2035 et le
plafond a priori de 63,2 gigawatts des
autorisations d'exploitation il faut
aussi procéder à une révision de la PPE
nous
retiré en retirer la trajectoire de
fermeture des douze réacteurs qui est
pour l'instant existe toujours alors que
nous sommes en train de légiférer sur
une loi d'urgence il faut enfin prévoir
que la loi quinquennale de sur l'énergie
attendue d'ici juillet acte de la
construction des nouveaux opère 2 et SMS
d'ici 2050 et précise les moyens
financiers et humains requis le deuxième
axe vise à garantir la sûreté à la
sécurité dans cette perspective j'ai
proposé d'intégrer les résilience au
changement climatique dans le mode
démonstration de sûreté des réacteurs
tant au stade de l'autorisation que de
leur est examen et la cyber résilience à
la protection des réacteurs contre les
actes de malveillance j'ai aussi voulu
constitutionner l'octroi des concessions
d'utilisation du domaine public maritime
à la prise en compte des risques de
submersion d'inondation et de recul du
traité
autre sujet j'ai entendu maintenir le
rapport quinquennal sur la sûreté
encadré le recours à la simplification
déclaration préalable dans le cadre du
réexamen des réacteurs et clarifier les
délais de la procédure de mise à l'arrêt
définitif enfin j'ai voulu moderniser le
fonctionnement de l'Autorité de sûreté
nucléaire en renforçant les attributions
de sa commission des sanctions et en
actualisant les règles évaluation
prescription infraction applicables
le troisième axe vise à associer les
collectivités territoriales et publics
pour se faire j'ai souhaité garantir que
les réacteurs ne puissent être
qualifiés d'intérêt général qu'après la
tenue du débat public j'ai aussi voulu
que les collectivités puissent entrer
dans un dialogue avec l'État pour la
modification de leurs documents
d'urbanisme j'ai également proposé
d'exclure les réacteurs du décompte Xan
car il s'agit d'un projet d'ampleur
national un autre enjeu a été garante et
de garantir la perception par les
collectivités de la taxe d'aménagement
le dernier axe vise à renforcer la
sécurité juridique des procédures tout
d'abord j'ai proposé que les travaux
pourront être anticipés le soi au frais
et au risque d'exploitant et après
information du public j'ai aussi voulu
qu'un décret détermine ses travaux après
la vie de la scène j'ai aussi garanti le
contenu de l'impact l'étude d'impact les
modalités de l'enquête publique ou
encore les consultations de la SN de
plus j'ai suggéré que la dérogation de
la lotière littorale soit attribuée au
cas par cas pour les ouvrages de
raccordement dans la continuité des
travaux du Sénas sur le projet de loi
d'accélération sur les renouvelables
autre point j'ai proposé de réduire à 6
ans le délai la procédure
d'expropriation d'en exclure les
ouvrages de raccordement les équipements
de fonctionnement et de prévoir des
garanties notamment de relogements des
habitants ou des indignations des
professionnels enfin j'ai ajouté deux
procédures manquantes une procédure de
régularisation de l'instance pour les
litiges liés au nouveau réacteurs une
distance de permis de construire pour
les travaux d'adaptation des réacteurs
résistants au total le texte issus de
notre commission équilibrée entre
l'effet de Saint-Pierre aussi exigence
renfortée sur la sûreté et la sécurité
je forme le vœu que ce texte cette
contribue à la relance du nucléaire dans
la crise énergétique une autre
traversons l'énergie nucléaire est un
atout pour offrir un coup de
l'électricité attractive
[Musique]
excusez-moi madame la Présidente je
voudrais remercier Alexis Coralie et
Clément et Sébastien ainsi que toute la
commission de leurs travaux merci la
parole est à Monsieur Pascal Martin
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président du Sénat madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires économiques monsieur le
Président de la Commission de la
management du territoire et du
développement durable mes chers
collègues la Commission de l'aménagement
du territoire et du développement
durable au nom de laquelle je m'exprime
aujourd'hui salut le signal sans
équivoque envoyé par le texte soumis à
l'examen du Sénat après de trop
nombreuses années d'atermoiements ayant
conduit à un délaissement de la filière
nucléaire préjudiciable tant d'un point
de vue climatique que du point de vue de
la préservation de notre souveraineté la
nouvelle impulsion énergétique et
industrielle et bienvenue elle est même
indispensable pour maintenir la France à
sa place de numéro 1 de l'électricité
décarbonée et soutenir l'électrification
des usages prévus par la stratégie
nationale bas carbone avec une
production pilotable en parallèle du
développement des énergies renouvelables
et de la réduction massive de
consommation énergétique
notre commission à toutefois regretté la
méthode consistant à aborder le
particulier avant le cadre général
il lui était préférable pour la clarté
des débats politiques de définir au
préalable les objectifs de la politique
énergétique dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation relative à l'énergie et au
climat qui doit être adopté au Parlement
dans le courant de l'année 2023
en dépit des réserves et remarque que je
vous présenterai ici succinctement notre
commission a donné un avis favorable au
projet de loi proposé
compte tenu du champ très restreint du
texte de sa grande technicité et du
calendrier des consultations
actuellement à l'oeuvre sur les projets
de 6 premiers EPR 2 et sur l'élaboration
de la stratégie française pour l'énergie
le climat notre commission a souhaité
apporter au texte des ajustements
essentiellement juridiques avec un
double objectif
premièrement
améliorer la sécurité juridique et la
lisibilité du texte afin de limiter les
risques contentieux qui affaibliraient
la relance souhaitée du nucléaire
français
deuxièmement
encadrer les marges de manœuvre laissées
au pouvoir réglementaire
sur le volet visant à encadrer les
marges laissées au pouvoir réglementaire
notre commission a souhaité que le
pouvoir réglementaire soit contraint
d'ordonner la mise à l'arrêt définitif
d'une installation nucléaire de base
ayant cessé de fonctionner pendant une
durée continue supérieure à deux ans dès
lors que l'absence de volonté et
l'incapacité de l'exploitant de remettre
son installation en service dans des
délais raisonnables sont constatés par
la puissance publique
cette option nous semblait équilibrer et
apporter une opportune valeur ajoutée
elle évitait les instructions inutiles
comme le souhaite le projet de loi sans
pour autant affaiblir le principe d'un
démantèlement des installations le plus
tôt possible après leur arrêt elle n'a
pas été retenue lors de nos débats en
commission
avant de conclure j'aimerais rappeler
que ce projet de loi
aussi bien vu qu'il soit aura un impact
limité sur la relance du nucléaire
français
l'accélération des procédures et la
réduction du risque contentieux ne
constitue que des leviers mineurs pour
assurer 1 en développement dans des
délais souhaités d'un nouveau parc de la
prolongation du parc existant dans des
conditions de sûreté adaptées les défis
qui devront être relevés dépassent en
réalité largement le périmètre du texte
et sont de deux ordres il relève d'une
part de la capacité des pouvoirs publics
et du secteur à opérer une indispensable
montée en compétences de la filière
et d'autre part assurer une
acceptabilité locale et nationale autour
de la relance du nucléaire en résumé et
en conclusion il conviendra en 2023 de
donner une visibilité suffisante aux
acteurs du nucléaire
l'anticipation à la fois indispensable à
la montée en compétences de la filière
et elle acceptabilité du nouveau
programme constitue sans aucun doute la
meilleure réponse au défi qui s'annonce
pour le nucléaire français je vous
remercie de votre attention merci chers
collègues alors nous passons à la
discussion de la motion pendant à
opposer la question préalable
Monsieur Daniel Salmon et les membres du
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
ont déposé une motion distribuée sur le
numéro 4 tendant à opposer la question
préalable au texte en discussion et je
donne la parole à Monsieur Daniel salmon
pour la motion et pour diminuer merci
madame le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues faut-il relancer la filière
nucléaire en France voilà en substance
la question qui nous est posée avec ce
projet de loi avec une approche
rationnelle la réponse est évidente
c'est non
pour plusieurs raisons tout d'abord en
mettant ce projet de loi l'ordre du jour
du Parlement le gouvernement ne respecte
pas le débat démocratique qui a lieu en
ce moment même nous sommes là dans le
droit fil de l'histoire du nucléaire une
concertation publique sur le mix
énergétique est actuellement en cours et
un débat organisé par la Commission
nationale du débat public est à l'oeuvre
également jusqu'au 27 février sur le
projet de construire une paire de paires
2 sur le site de painly et plus
largement sur le programme de
construction de six nouveaux réacteurs
ce projet arrive également avant les
débats qui doivent se tenir autour de la
future loi quinquennale de programmation
énergique climat dont doit découler la
programmation purée annuelle de
l'énergie et la stratégie nationale bas
carbone cette alu Sud c'est débats et
évidemment pas avant que sera défini
notre mix énergétique et je note que sur
ce point nous avons un accord avec le
rapporteur
en plaçant ce projet de loi dans ce
calendrier l'idée du gouvernement est de
gagner quelques mois quelques mois en
comparaison 34 années études et
constructions de l'EPR qui n'a pas
encore fourni 1 mégawattheure
demandez au parlementaire de voter un
projet de loi qui acte une relance de
nucléaire avant cette loi de
programmation alors qu'aucune obligation
légale ou réglementaire de l'impose nous
paraît largement prématuré profondément
antidémocratique quel est l'objectif
sinon celui de mettre les acteurs
concernés ainsi que nos concitoyens
devant le fait accompli
toutes les garanties doivent être
apportées pour que ces choix politiques
soient pris dans le respect du Parlement
et de nos concitoyens et pas décidé une
inilatéralement par le chef de l'État à
Belfort le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire s'oppose au fondement même du
projet la relance du nucléaire nous ne
pouvons que nous y opposer même si nous
sommes lucides sur le fait de devoir
encore hélas composé avec le nucléaire
existant à certains temps car depuis des
années l'inaction est de mise sur
l'efficacité la sobriété et que le
rythme de développement des énergies
renouvelables n'a pas été respectée
il n'est pas acceptable de relancer des
activités nucléaires polluantes et
dangereuses qui nous engagent sur au
moins un siècle alors que les menaces de
tous ordres et en particulier les
bouleversements climatiques vont
accroître de façon considérable les
risques encourus par cette filière qui
peut vraiment prédire le climat et
l'état de la planète en 2050 alors que
nous avons déjà des normes incertitudes
sur les 5 ans à venir ce n'est pas
acceptable d'autant que des solutions
alternatives totalement crédibles non
dangereuse plus rapide à mettre en
oeuvre et bien moins cher sont apportés
de main nous tenons en premier lieu à
souligner l'incohérence des objectifs
affichés dans d'exposer des motifs quant
à la lutte contre les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre le temps de développement
des nouveaux réacteurs et long très long
soyons lucides pas avant 15 ans
probablement 20 ans le dérèglement
climatique demande des solutions ayant
un impact fort dans les dix années à
venir
maintenant qu'il faut agir il faut agir
radicalement d'ailleurs le GIEC classe
le nucléaire loin derrière les énergies
renouvelables et les économies d'énergie
au regard des objectifs de développement
durable qu'il a établi en prenant en
compte les coûts la nécessité d'un
soutien public très important l'enjeu de
la gestion des déchets les impacts sur
les ressources en eau la pollution liée
au mines d'uranium le risque de
prolifération et j'en passe nous ne
pouvons exposer la question du nucléaire
sans parler de ses enjeux de sûreté les
impacts des accidents nucléaires
survenus dans le passé perdure 36 ans
après Tchernobyl des territoires entiers
restent contaminés il ne suffit pas de
minimiser l'effet d'une manière
mensongère dans une BD pour que cela
devienne réalité il faudra des siècles
pour que la radioactivité disparaisse
des sols à Fukushima il faut toujours
continuer à refroidir le combustible
plus d'un million de tonnes d'eau
contaminés restent présentes sur le site
en France un accident nucléaire n'est
pas une vue de un tel scénario a été
chiffré par l'IRSN jusqu'à 430 milliards
d'euros pour un accident majeur
selon Grégory Jasco ancien président de
l'Autorité sûreté nucléaire américaine
les accidents nucléaires graves sont
inésctables le nucléaire est un malade
chronique qu'il faut surveiller sans
cesse en temps de paix mais il faut
ajouter à cette maladie une
vulnérabilité intrinsèque face aux
agressions extérieures ce qui en fait
une énergie profondément dangereuse nous
pouvons le constater encore aujourd'hui
avec la situation gravissime autour de
la centrale de zapporica en Ukraine
autre sujet de vulnérabilité celui qui
va se manifester de façon croissante
avec les bouleversements climatiques aux
du niveau de la mer ose de la
température et baisse du lit du débit
sur les fleuves tempêtes et tornades de
plus en plus fréquente et violente
inondations qui peut prévoir ce qui se
produira avec des EPR conçus aujourd'hui
et qui entreront en production en 2040
dans un monde à plus de degrés et
termineront leur carrière en 2100 a
peut-être plus 4 degrés
certains associent facilement nucléaires
et souveraineté mais depuis quand le
nucléaire rime-t-il avec indépendance
énergétique nos 210 mines ont produit un
totalitaire l'équivalent de 10 ans de
consommation elles sont toutes fermées
depuis 20 ans aujourd'hui 100% du
combustible est important c'est
importants se font au prix de
compromission avec certains régimes
autoritaires et au mépris de la santé
des populations locales au Niger par
exemple l'extraction d'uranium génial
des poussières radioactives empoisonnent
d'eau et la nourriture et affecte la
santé des habitants quant au coût du
démantèlement des centrales en fin de
vie là comme ailleurs EDF avance des
chiffres complètement fantaisistes
déconnecter des réalités
les déchets sont l'autre bout de la
chaîne d'un cycle qui n'est pas du tout
fermé malgré ce que l'on veut dire
stocker dans des piscines exportées non
compati comptabilisés ils attendent une
issus peut-être aussi géo pour les plus
radioactifs un nom puissant sans retour
au risque et au cou sous-estimé quant au
moins radioactif issu des démantèlements
la solution avancée semble la
dissémination la dilution dans
l'environnement tout cela a et aura des
coûts faramineux et c'est bien le
contribuable qui devra mettre la main au
portefeuille c'est une habitude pour le
nucléaire mais où va-t-on vraiment
gagner du temps avec ce projet de loi ce
ne sont pas les procédures
administratives en matière d'urbanisme
ou de droits de l'environnement qui
freine le déploiement du nucléaire comme
le laisse croire ce texte c'est un Alice
simpliste ne permet pas de poser les
vraies questions sur les défaillances et
les contraintes structurelles de
l'énergie atomique il faut plutôt
chercher dans les domaines du travail de
conception des études travailler de
l'instruction technique et à tout cela
s'ajoute l'absence de compétences qui
génère les malfaçons en cascade
j'en viens au fleuron LEPR la définition
même de ce qu'on appelle un fiasco
industriel et économique mise en cause
en juillet 2020 par la Cour des contes
elles-mêmes à travers un rapport
extrêmement sévère sur la filière ce
rapport revient sur la longue liste des
problèmes responsables des retards
interminables et du surcoût du chantier
de Flamanville ainsi que des autres
réacteurs en construction de Parlement
surtout la Cour des comptes met en doute
l'opportunité de relancer un nouveau
parc nucléaire appelant l'État à se
demander si d'autres options de
production d'électricité ne sont pas
plus pertinentes et moins chères car le
Pr c'est aussi un gouffre financier ce
qui pourrait seulement interroger
devient proprement scandaleux lorsque le
coût estimé pour flamand ville atteint
désormais près de 20 milliards sachant
que le chantier n'est toujours pas
terminé quel acteur du privé peut se
permettre un budget multiplié par 6
comment faire confiance pour construire
d'autres EPR à une filière incapable de
gérer un budget et un calendrier
le retour d'expérience sur Sophia SCO de
l'opéra est de plus incomplet refusé de
tirer les leçons de ce chantier
catastrophique pour engager la France
avec de nouveaux réacteurs qui
connaîtront très probablement à leur
tour retard sur coup et malfaçon n'est
pas acceptable décidez le lancement de
nouveaux projets revient à mépriser la
démocratie la sûreté et les générations
futures qui devront porter le poids de
ces nouveaux boulets à leurs pieds à
quel moment alors que cet échec
industriel économique n'est plus à
démontrer il est opportun de remettre
une pièce dans la machine le
gouvernement comme l'administration
sarkbou sur des schémas du 20e siècle on
a parlé de Pompidou tout à l'heure en
restant habité par cette mystique qui
veut que la grandeur de la France passe
nécessairement par une industrie
nucléaire triomphante à l'énergie
soi-disant pas cher et abondante se
lancer dans cette trajectoire de
nouveaux réacteurs c'est mettre
quasiment tous nos œufs dans le même
panier avec toutes les incertitudes sur
les délais les coûts et les garanties de
sécurité que cela comporte de tels
investissements asphyxie tous les autres
besoins de financement pour la sobriété
l'efficacité et les renouvelable c'est
proprement irresponsables
pour conclure les propositions des
centers et sénatrices écologistes sont
claires les économies d'énergie couplées
à une rapide montée en puissance des
données une production tout à la fois
décentralisée en réseau voilà la vraie
transition énergétique que nous
défendons un scénario 100% renouvelable
techniquement réalisable l'étude RTE
aïeul la démontré un scénario pourvoyeur
d'emplois davantage résilient face une
crise et plus rapide à mettre en œuvre
il sera mieux intégré dans les
territoires et permettra la
réappropriation du système énergétique
par les citoyens parce que nous ne
voulons pas avoir raison à titre costume
parce que la centralisation du pouvoir
qui va de pair avec l'énergie nucléaire
n'est pas démocratique parce que nous
refusons d'adhérer à lébriété
énergétique que nous vend l'énergie
nucléaire et qui invite à retarder la
transition parce qu'il nous faut des
solutions applicates immédiatement si
chers collègues parce que nous refusons
de léguer aux générations futures le
poids
faire vivre la démocratie le rapporteur
a eu 20 secondes tout à l'heure il est
peut-être raison
quelle est la vie de la Commission
le rapporteur c'est pas
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues
l'exception d'y recevoir méditer soulevé
à l'encontre du projet de loi n'est pas
pertinente
d'une part la vie du Conseil d'État n'a
soulevé aucune difficulté d'ordre
constitutionnel ou conventionnelle à
l'encontre du projet de loi d'autre part
notre commission s'est assurée que les
consultations et bien été affectées
celle du Conseil national des
transitions écologiques du Conseil
national d'évaluation des normes de la
Mission interministérielle de l'eau
notamment enfin si notre commission
regretté la séquençage l'évocateur à
l'examen parlementaire qui aurait dû
commencer par le projet c'est le seul
point où on se retrouve
puis le projet de loi d'accélération du
nucléaire puis projet de loi
d'accélération des renouvelables c'est
qu'on sache
vos chers collègues ne fragilise pas
pour autant la constitutionnalité du
texte les débats publics ainsi prévu sur
le programme de nouveau nucléaires dont
les deux paires de Conlie est le mix
énergétique se poursuivent sous l'égide
de la Commission nationale du débat
public j'ajoute que notre commission est
très sensible à la question de la
participation du public c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons prévu en
commission d'une part que la
qualification de projet d'intérêt
général ne soit affectés qu'après le
débat public et d'autre part que le
gouvernement précise la représentation
nationale les sites soumis à la
participation du public enfin les
autorisations de création de nouveaux
réacteurs ou d'examens périodique du de
ceux existant à l'article 9 donc c'est
un avis d'effort rabat de la Commission
merci quelle est la vie du gouvernement
madame la ministre
sans surprise mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ce sera un avis des favorable
défavorable d'abord comme la très bien
rappelée monsieur le rapporteur parce
que précisément un débat public est en
cours il y en a même deux qui sont en
cours pour associer le public pour
interroger les Français un premier débat
public car nous avons suivi en ce sens
la Commission nationale du débat public
sur le mix énergétique pour l'ensemble
de notre pays pour les années qui
viennent un deuxième débat public
spécifique sur la première paire de
réacteurs à panli mais qui était
l'argile à l'acceptabilité du nucléaire
c'est débats se déroulent et nous
respecterons cette démocratie
participative et nous verserons les
résultats de ces deux débats publics
pour la programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie et c'est pour cette région
mais je crois que tout le monde l'a bien
compris que la loi sur la programmation
plus réelle de l'énergie la loi énergie
climat sera présentée à la fin de ce
débat public et après avoir fait les
concertations nécessaire au bon
fonctionnement de notre démocratie et ça
arrivera donc dans le courant de l'année
2023 alors pourquoi ce projet de loi sur
les autorisations et bien vous l'avez
compris parce que ces autorisations
elles prennent plusieurs années compte
tenues de la complexification de notre
droit de l'urbanisme de notre droit sur
la loi littorale depuis le moment où
nous avons construit des premiers
réacteurs nucléaires je rappelle que
c'était à la fin des années 70 au début
des années 80 et donc il ne faudrait pas
que ces procédures administratives
techniques
se ralentissent de plusieurs années et
c'est de ça qu'il est question
aujourd'hui c'est du dépôt des premiers
dossiers du nucléaire qui doivent être
préparés aujourd'hui si vous voulez que
nous ayons des réacteurs nucléaires en
2035 en 2037 comme c'est l'objectif du
gouvernement et donc nous ne confondons
pas vitesse et précipitations nous
sommes dans l'anticipation c'est très
exactement de quoi il est question et
c'est pour cette raison que je vous
inviterai à vous opposer à cette motion
qui met en danger notre mix énergétique
à long terme et qui ne répond pas aux
enjeux climatiques je veux juste
répondre sur quelques points que vous
avez mentionné oui le GIEC considère que
l'énergie nucléaire est une des réponses
au réchauffement climatique c'est écrit
noir sur blanc dans leur rapport ce
n'est pas majoritaire mais c'est écrit
noir sur blanc dans la rapport et
monsieur le sénateur Dantec vous les
connaissez mieux que moi donc je me
perdrai pas de vous faire
l'injure de vous estimer sur ce sujet là
deuxième élément s'agissant des déchets
nous avons des propositions et nous nous
avons je veux dire des mesures qui sont
à l'oeuvre aujourd'hui vous nous
interrogez sur la limite qui est la
façon dont les mines sont exploitées
pour l'uranium dois-je vous rappeler que
dans les énergies renouvelables il faut
du lithium il faut du cobalt il faut des
aimants permanents et que donc les mêmes
questions sont posées aussi pour les une
énergie renouvelable et que s'agissant
de l’uranium en fait elles ont été
peut-être mieux anticipées que sur les
énergies renouvelables c'est d'ailleurs
un gros travail pour mon ministère en ce
moment et au niveau européen voilà je ne
prolongerai pas le propos mais je pense
que les éléments essentiels ils sont
mais la ministreham pour explication de
vote monsieur Fabienne
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues bon vous savez que
nous ne partageons pas
les arguments vont sépare notre collègue
et le groupe écologiste sur quel mix
électrique ils en ont tout à fait le
droit et quand les arguments sont posés
et il y aura un débat nous nous
partageons le fait d'un mix électrique
avec une part non négligeable de
nucléaire et le développement des
énergies renouvelables dans un débat
100% public vous le savez nous ne
lâcherons pas sur cette question là
cependant
sur la question que pose notre collègue
Daniel Salmon et le groupe écologiste
dans cette question préalable
pardonnez-moi de dire qu'ils ont raison
sur la forme
vous nous dites le débat public on
mettra tout ça on le versera au débat
oui mais quand même même si c'est
constitutionnel monsieur le rapporteur
c'est une question politique
on n'ouvre pas un débat public puis
ensuite en même temps on fait le débat à
l'Assemblée c'est exactement la même
chose lorsqu'on nous dit ayant le débat
rapidement sur les retraites on
conservera en même temps les partenaires
sociaux deuxièmement
on est amené
ici à prendre une décision sur le
nucléaire sans être venu sur la loi de
la PPE
il l'objectif c'est 50% et moi je suis
désolé de le dire vous prenez le
problème à l'envers ayons et n'arrêtons
pas de vous le dire depuis juillet le
débat politique et les objectifs puis
ensuite viennent les textes qui les
mettent en adéquation mais là on prend
le système à l'envers et je suis désolé
de dire que ce que nous faisons là va
contrevenir à la PPE toujours en place
la dernière chose je finis par ça
imaginons que dans la PPE ce n'est pas
mon souhait mais nous prenions le
le postulat de RTE 100% énergies
renouvelable ce que nous faisons ici
aujourd'hui et nous aurons réunis deux
ou trois jours pour rien et donc sur
cette question là nous nous abstiendrons
sur la question préalable de nos
collègues écologistes je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Houlgate
monsieur le Président du Sénat madame la
ministre mes chers collègues sans
reprendre l'argumentation de Fabien gay
pour lequel nous souscrivons en partie
en ce qui concerne la procédure je
voudrais simplement apporter une
précision nous n'examinons pas
aujourd'hui le texte du Gouvernement
texte qui était pour qui avait pour
objectif d'anticiper sur le plan
administratif et juridique des décisions
à venir qui seront donc élaborées par la
future stratégie française climat
énergie que nous appelons tous de nos
vœux mais nous examinons bien le texte
qui a été voté par la commission des
affaires économiques du Sénat et qui a
d'une certaine façon modifiée voire ou
m'excuserait du terme dévoyé le texte
initial pour traduire dans une loi le
discours du président de la République à
Belfort et même elle est au-delà des
intentions présidentielles alors que la
Commission aménagement du territoire et
du développement durable saisie pour
avis avait j'allais dire de façon
responsable et avec rigueur sécuriser
les textes comme la mentionné le
rapporteur pour avis Pascal Martin tout
à l'heure en précisant notamment la
notion de proximité immédiate en
précisant le séquençage des travaux et
en définissant les bâtiments sensibles
en clarifiant et en veillant à ce que
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire puisse
toujours assumer ses fonctions la
commission des affaires économiques
j'allais dire sous l'ombre de Pierre
Messmer a établi une nouvelle
programmation énergétique qui va
s'imposer à la PPE qui va chanter toutes
les procédures de concertation et ainsi
tout débat public s'apparentant d'une
certaine façon à une forme de déni de
démocratie consultative nous ne sommes
plus dans les années 70 il faut d'une
certaine façon remettre les choses dans
l'ordre alors même si on déplore d'une
certaine façon que le que ce texte
viennent de façon prématurée on ne peut
que constater que si on le limite à ces
aspects administratifs et juridique à ce
moment-là notre stratégie au niveau du
du groupe des élus socialistes
écologistes et républicains sera de
poursuivre l'examen du texte et en
essayant de de revenir aux amendements
tel qu'ils avaient été proposés par la
commission d'aménagement du territoire
nous nous abstiendrons donc merci
Monsieur Bonhomme
merci madame la Présidente oui sur cette
question de préalable je crois que c'est
toujours amusant de voir une certaine
illustration d'une certaine dogmatisme
je reconnais au vert une certaine
continuité dans l'erreur puisqu'ils ont
toujours été contre nucléaire et pour
ENR mais dire que le processus
démocratique n'a pas été respecté on
peut en discuter on peut pas dire qu'on
n'en discute pas depuis pas mal d'années
ici
même si je serai d'accord avec
l'inversion du calendrier qui n'a pas sa
logique effectivement présenter un texte
en air nucléaire plus une Pepe en toute
fin ça paraît quand même assez illogique
mais je voudrais dire c'est parce que
vous avez un processus démocratique
accompli que ça vous garantit une bonne
décision moi je rappelle ici quand même
que les orientations prises en 2011 avec
un accord électoral entre les Verts et
les socialistes à l'époque en 2011 le
candidat Hollande qui n'était pas encore
président et qui a mis en oeuvre cela a
été un processus ratifié par les
élections c'est un contestables c'est un
choix tout à fait démocratique mais qui
se révèle aujourd'hui catastrophique
donc vous voyez ça n'est pas la garantie
d'une certaine pression c'est une
garantie de bonne décision que d'avoir
un parfait processus démocratique ce que
je voulais dire par rapport à ce
d'évoquer dans cette question préalable
autre élément le calendrier serait
prématuré moi je crois surtout qu'il est
tardif et qu'on a mis des années à
changer d'orientation et le président
République n'est pas allé à Belfort
c'est pas vrai il est allé à Canossa et
c'est un revirement madame ministre que
vous ne voulez pas reconnaître
aujourd'hui quoi que vous en disiez et
puis enfin un dernier mot quand même sur
j'ai une je n'ai pas une admiration
totale pour pour le gourou médiatique
qu'après représenté Greta Thunberg mais
devenant adulte il y a quelques mois
elle a reconnu quand même qu'il valait
mieux avoir les centrales nucléaires que
les centrales à charbon vous voyez que
tout arrive en attendant entre temps on
paye aujourd'hui ça très cher et on n'a
pas fini madame la ministre de corriger
toutes ces erreurs stratégiques
merci chers collègues monsieur Moga
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
même s'il y avait mes collègues de
l'Union centriste nous regrettons le
désordre errant inhérent à l'examen
parlementaire de notre politique
énergétique
si nous regrettons qu'il n'y ait pas une
loi globale sur l'énergie mais parce que
ce texte que nous allons examiner va
permettre de diminuer les freins de
lever les blocages de contourner les
obstacles à la construction de nouvelles
centrales à la modernisation des
réacteurs existants et parce que le
nucléaire est aujourd'hui incontournable
dans notre mix énergétique pour toutes
ces raisons
nous ne voterons pas cette question
préalable je vous remercie merci chers
collègues alors je vais maintenant
consulter le Sénat sur la motion
tendante à opposer la question préalable
je rappelle que l'adoption de cette
motion entraînerait le rejet du texte en
discussion alors qui est pour la motion
qui est contre
qui s'abstient la motion est donc pas
adoptée
alors dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane Ravier pour 3 minutes
madame la présidente madame le ministre
mes chers collègues nous sommes une
majorité ici à être d'accord pour
simplifier et alléger le carcan normatif
qui pèse sur la construction de
nouvelles centrales nucléaires et
l'entretien du parc existant cependant
nous ne saurions réduire le débat sur ce
projet de loi de simple allègements
administratifs sans évoquer la vision et
le cap de notre politique énergétique si
tenter qu'il en existe encore un la
temporalité de l'examen de ce texte est
d'abord doublement ma chronique nous
sommes encore soumis à la mauvaise
trajectoire de la précédente
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
2018-2023 et nous légiférons sans
connaître les objectifs pour 2023 2028
fixé dans quelques mois seulement en
effet dans la continuité de la politique
menée depuis 2012 l'exécutif a prévu en
2018 la fermeture de 14 réacteurs
nucléaires d'ici 2035 pour passer la
part du nucléaire de 80 à 50% de notre
mix énergétique national les deux
réacteurs de la centrale de Fessenheim
ont ainsi été fermés en 2020 après 43
ans de fonctionnement
soit la moitié de la vie de certains
centrales aux États-Unis et alors que
nous avons une ingénierie de pointe en
la matière vous êtes pour le départ à la
retraite à 64 ans pour tous sauf pour
les réacteurs nucléaires alors puisque
ce texte prévoit désormais le départ à
la retraite des réacteurs au-delà de 60
ans il serait incompréhensible de ne pas
revenir sur cette décision car cette
centrale ne présentait aucun
dysfonctionnement mettant en cause la
sûreté de l'installation à cette
problématique s'ajoute celle d'ordre
juridique consistant à savoir si l'on
peut définir une stratégie souveraine
indépendamment de celle fixée par les
institutions européennes sous le regard
attentif et la main interventionniste de
l'Allemagne car aujourd'hui notre
filière nucléaire est la première
victime des choix de Bruxelles que vous
appliquez avec le zèle qui vous
caractérise alors oui je ferai tout pour
actionner les fables leviers qui sont
les nôtres en faveur de la prolongation
des centrales existantes et la
construction de père de nouvelles
génération et de petits réacteurs
modulaires mais
je ne participerai pas à l'enthousiasme
communicationnel autour de ce tout petit
texte rédigé à la rate car je suis
chaque jour aux côtés des Français qui
voient leurs factures énergétique
explosé en raison de vos choix
désastreux je suis au côté des artisans
et des entreprises précarisées non pas à
cause de la guerre en Ukraine mais à
cause de vos renoncements sur la filière
nucléaire notamment l'abandon du projet
Astrid après celui de super Phénix je
suis aux côtés des maires qui voient
leur budget rabougri overrant le
développement de leur commune les
événements du week-end en Allemagne sont
à l'image parfaite de ce que nous ne
voulons pas voir chez nous une guerre
sociale des villages que l'on détruit
pour des mines et des
ignobles éoliennes qui s'étendent avec
un appétit sans fin c'est pourtant ce
qui se profile avec la réouverture du
site du site de Saint-Avold et le
développement des énergies
intermittentes votre entêtement
idéologique et vos petits accords
électoraux avec les talibans verdoyants
qui n'a n'ont jamais assez on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure conduisent le
pays au désastre économique et
écologique votre gouvernement est frappé
par une inflation de son incompétence
mais ce sont les Français une fois de
plus qui paieront le prix merci
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Nathalie Delattre pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen pour 5 minutes
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la Présidente de
commission monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues les inquiétudes
exprimées à la fin de l'année 2022 et
les plans de délestage annoncés dans la
presse constitue une piqûre de rappel
s'il en fallait une quant à la
vulnérabilité de notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement en énergie nous
échapperons probablement aux coupures
cet hiver grâce à de multiples efforts
les Français sur leur réduction en
consommation d'énergie le redémarrage de
nombreux réacteurs dès ce mois-ci et aux
températures clémentes des trois
dernières semaines mais pour combien de
temps la période qui s'écoulera d'ici
2050 et qui correspond en même temps à
la teinte espérer de la neutralité
carbone et à la fermeture des réacteurs
nucléaires existants sera déterminante
pour préserver nos conditions
d'existence et participer à la lutte
contre le changement climatique
nous sommes donc au tournant de la
sortie progressive de l'air des énergies
fossiles qui au regard du retard pris
s'annonce à brut cela implique notamment
de décarboner tous les secteurs à
commencer par celui de l'énergie et donc
de doubler notre production
d'électricité les différents exercices
de prospective récents que ce soit le
rapport transition 2050 de l'ADEME ou
futurs énergétiques 2050 de RTE entre
autres permettent d'éclairer le débat
public et la représentation nationale
que nous sommes tous les scénaris
présentent de fortes incertitudes quant
à la disponibilité des technologies le
contexte social la géopolitique et la
macroéconomie les besoins en formation
ou le financement dans tous les cas le
gros RDSE soutient de longue date un mix
énergétique diversifié qui combine le
nucléaire les énergies renouvelables et
l'hydrogène afin de garantir la
stabilité du système électrique qui doit
demeurer pilotable
en outre la prolongation du
fonctionnement des centrales actuelles à
60 ans dans le cadre du scénario n03
poursuivi par la commission des affaires
économiques alors qu'elles ont été
conçues pour une durée de 40 ans bien
que souhaitable ne peut être considéré
comme acquise aussi il faut aller vite
et relancer un nouveau programme
nucléaire après l'examen d'un projet de
loi dédié à l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables on ne peut donc que se
réjouir du retour en grâce de l'atome à
la fois en France et sur la scène
internationale en pari sur le nucléaire
en confirmant ses choix historiques qui
lui ont permis de produire une
électricité largement décarbonée la
France ne fait pas cavalier seul
cependant le temps long de la
construction des réacteurs implique de
décider dès à présent pour compter sur
une première mise en service en 2035 et
un parc de 14 EPR en 2050
mais accélérer ne doit pas être synonyme
d'escamotage de la démocratie
participative ou représentative ou
encore des règles de sécurité et de
sûreté c'est bien ce que sécurise ce
projet de loi facilitant la construction
de nouveaux réacteurs sur les sites
existants ou alors proximité immédiate
cela permettra de s'assurer de
l'acceptabilité des projets comme cela
est le cas de la centrale du Blayais
dont je défends la candidature de la
construction d'une paire d'EPR au côté
de nombreux mers entreprises et
habitants de ce territoire girondin
j'avais déposé un amendement visant à ce
que les études de faisabilité sur la
construction de ces réacteurs soit rendu
dans un délai d'un an à compter de la
promulgation de la loi afin de donner de
la visibilité au territoire à ce
territoire qui dispose aussi de tous les
atouts pour les accueillir pourtant
examen examiner en commission il a été
déclaré irrécevable au titre de
l'article 40 de la Constitution dont
acte
mais nous le savons les défis de la
filière nucléaire ne reposent pas
uniquement sur les démarches
administratives le projet de loi ne
produira qu'un gain de temps mineur
certes non négligeable avec un
raccourcissement des délais de 56 mois
selon le rapporteur au fond mais des
obstacles plus colossaux nous attendent
et de plusieurs ordres les délais
industriels les solutions à trouver au
problème de construction à Paris sur le
chantier de Flamanville la formation et
le maintien des compétences la sécurité
d'approvisionnement en uranium dans un
contexte géopolitique peu prévisible le
réchauffement climatique qui soulève la
question du refroidissement des
centrales la gestion des déchets la
revalorisation du combustible le
financement ou encore les effets de
l'arène sur la situation de EDF c'est un
défi industriel considérable pour une
filière qui se tient prête à le relever
aussi il est dommage alors que le débat
public est actuellement en train de se
tenir pour la construction de deux EPR à
panli ainsi que sur le programme du
nouveau nucléaire de ne pas disposer
plus en avant d'informations concernant
son financement tout comme il est
regrettable que nous ne puissions pas
avoir à ce jour la liste décide
d'implantations des 8 EPR
supplémentaires enfin si l'on ne peut
lever les incertitudes technologiques et
financières quel que soit le scénario
choisi le vent du moins les incertitudes
politiques et juridiques le groupe RDSO
votera donc en faveur du projet de loi
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
Madame Sophie prima pour le groupe les
républicains et pour 8 minutes chers
collègues
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président du Sénat madame la ministre
monsieur les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues ce projet de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui ne peut masquer
madame la ministre la responsabilité du
gouvernement et de sa majorité dans le
déclin de la filière du nucléaire fin
2022 au moment même où plus que jamais
nous avions besoin de cette source
d'énergie pour faire face aux
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine la
moitié de nos réacteurs était encore à
l'arrêt symptômes visibles d'une
situation plus invisible mais
structurellement grave en réalité
jusqu'au discours de Belfort tenu fort
opportunément à la toute fin du
précédent quinquennat à revers de la
politique menée jusque-là le
gouvernement a totalement délaissé la
filière du nucléaire allant même ne
l'oublions pas jusqu'à céder nos
capacités de production des turbines
nucléaires d'Alstom dans une bataille
géoéconomique et géopolitique épique
vous dites
la ministre ce matin dans Le Figaro
qu'au cours du premier quinquennat vous
avez consolidé la filière via Areva et
Framatome mais madame la ministre
c'était quand même le minimum fallait-il
aussi fragiliser ces deux acteurs
industriels majeurs vous dites que
depuis 3 ans dans France relance et dans
France 2030 vous avez alloué de fortes
sommes au nucléaire mais pouvons-nous
rappeler les chiffres
478 470 millions d'euros pour France
relance un milliard deux pour France
2030 dois-je avoir la cruauté de
rappeler que nous avons voté dans le PLF
2023 plus de 50 milliards d'euros de
boucliers énergétiques de tous ordres
pour soutenir notre économie sans aucun
investissement à la clé 50 milliards
d'eau dans le sable sur un an face à un
milliard cinq pour semer l'énergie de
demain le compte n'y est pas
alors le gouvernement a poursuivi la
fermeture des réacteurs existants
décidaient lors du quinquennat précédent
sans rien remettre en cause de la loi
transition énergétique de 2015 il a acté
les 14 arrêts de réacteurs en 20 ans et
exécuter Fessenheim en 2020 ce
gouvernement qui fait aujourd'hui du
nucléaire un élément central de la
transition énergétique avec la sobriété
les énergies renouvelables a fait preuve
d'un attentisme regrettable et coupable
pourtant les occasions étaient
nombreuses mais pas de décision pour la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs lors
de la révision de notre planification
énergétique nationale dans énergie
climat en 2019 ou dans la PPE de 2020
une nouvelle occasion manquée lors de
climat résilience en 2021 et je me
souviens madame la ministre des lourdes
de difficultés voire des sarcasmes que
nous avons rencontrées dans cette
hémicycle pour faire passer un principe
pourtant de bon sens celui de
l'interdiction de toute nouvelle
fermeture de réacteurs
motif de sûreté en l'absence d'études
d'impact sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement de notre énergie et
sur les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre je me souviens
que la ministre de l'Énergie d'alors
avait même qualifié aux bancs le travail
de notre commission je cite de ni fait
ni à faire alors oui le discours a
changé mais les annonces du discours de
Belfort et les six opère 2 restent en
deçà des besoins le scénario n03 de RTE
demande la construction de 14 PA2 et de
4 gigawatts de SMR et encore ce scénario
ne tient pas en compte le risque de non
prolongations des réacteurs au-delà de
60 ans ce qui peut arriver ni les
besoins en électricité qui pourrait
naître de la réindustrialisation des
territoires ou du développement
d'hydrogène le discours a changé oui
mais la situation de notre parc
nucléaire reste préoccupante la
fermeture de la centrale de Fessenheim
nous a privé de 1,8 gigawatts soit
l'équivalent de 1800 éoliennes c'est
l'équivalent de 10 millions de tonnes
d'économies de CO2 mais surtout ce
manque d'ambition pour le nucléaire à as
c'est une filière qui se croyant déclin
n'a plus attiré les talents en nombre
suffisant ni le volume des
investissements nécessaires comme en
témoigne par exemple la baisse de 70
millions du budget du CEA entre 2017 et
2021 et l'arrêtable du projet Astrid en
2019 les Français ne doivent pas
aujourd'hui être éblouis par la valence
soudaine de projets de loi énergie et
oubliés les conséquences délétères de
cette politique de l'abandon RTE
n'a-t-elle pas placé la France en
situation de vigilance particulière
jusqu'en 2024 en matière de sécurité
d'approvisionnement l'ADEME évoquait une
érosion tendancielle de la production
nucléaire depuis 10 ans la SN un système
électrique sans marge il est donc
urgent
urgent d'agir au-delà du texte de
simplification aujourd'hui proposée le
gouvernement doit lancer la construction
effective des réacteurs les six annoncés
les 8 à l'étude il doit aussi proposer
un modèle de financement car le groupe
EDF ne peut financer seul les EPR dont
le coût des six premiers sera de 46
milliards au bas mot le gouvernement
doit aussi
offrir un plan d'attractivité des
métiers et des compétences et je sais
que madame la ministre vous êtes engagé
là-dessus pour garantir la main d'oeuvre
nécessaire aux EPR 2 30 000 emplois pour
les six premiers enfin et surtout la
recherche de développement doit être
soutenue pour renforcer nos capacités
d'innovation et d'attractivité notamment
dans les réacteurs de quatrième
génération ou dans la poursuite du
projet ITER car l'énergie du 22ème
siècle mes chers collègues s'invente
aujourd'hui et comme l'a dit notre
excellent rapporteur le nucléaire de
demain ne sera pas celui d'hier c'est
donc à ces conditions que la relance du
nucléaire pourra être réalisée et notre
souveraineté retrouvée car le nucléaire
est un levier de souveraineté
énergétique certes j'entends l'argument
de nos collègues des dépendances à
l'uranium c'est un argument juste mais
qui est vrai également pour les EnR en
termes de terres rares pour les aimants
d'éoliennes par exemple mais la réponse
à ces dépendances de la de notre
dépendance à des ressources non
disponibles sur notre territoire est
dans la recherche dans le bouillonnement
de l'innovation dans l'optimisation et
dans le recyclage de ces ressources le
nucléaire est une énergie qui offre aux
Français et aux entreprises de notre
pays un coup de l'électricité inférieure
aux autres pays européens c'est
d'ailleurs bien le sujet pour nos amis
allemands il est un levier indispensable
de transition énergétique avec des
émissions en excédant pas si grave par
kWh son développement ne s'oppose pas à
celui des énergies renouvelables
arrêtons cette bataille passée au
contraire toute production des carbonées
et bonne à prendre pour atteindre
l'objectif de neutralité carbone d'ici
2050 neutralité carbone adoptée à
l'initiative de notre commission au
Sénat dans la loi énergique climat de
2019 le développement grande énergie
nucléaire est sans doute par ailleurs
l'une des conditions du développement
d'hydrogène qui pourrait tout à fait
être produit à grande échelle à partir
de l'électricité de nos réacteurs alors
oui madame la ministre Commission a
transformé ce test technique en
affirmation d'une volonté politique pour
réussir enfin la relance nucléaire pour
donner ce signal tant attendu depuis 10
ans au-delà de la simplification
normative nous avons souhaité initier
une véritable trajectoire de relance
pour un nucléaire plus abondant plus sûr
plus rapide plus innovant nous ne
pouvions nous résoudre à dire comme vous
le faites dans le texte d'origine qu'il
faut accélérer l'installation de
nouveaux réacteurs accélérer la
prolongation des centrales actuels et en
même temps continuer à acter les
prochaines fermetures des 12 anciens
réacteurs actifs c'est une contradiction
flagrante cette coordination au
juridique de cohérence politique
d'affirmation d'une ambition énergétique
devait être en fait sinon madame la
ministre rien de ce projet de loi ne
ferait sens notre groupe les
républicains apprendra donc ses
responsabilités et votre à ce texte
parce qu'enrichi par la commission des
affaires économiques merci chers
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Franck
mais non vide pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues un grand lorrain
Pierre Messmer en 1974 alors Premier
ministre déclarait notre grande chance
c'est l'énergie électrique d'origine
nucléaire
malheureusement depuis trop d'années
d'inaction d'hésitation d'atter nos
amants et de renoncement trop de choix
stratégiques souvent guidés par des
opportunités politiques courtes
sacrifiée au profit de collision de
circonstances ont fragilisé ce Florent
industriel tout cela malheureusement
conduit au désinvestissement dans la
filière à un affaiblissement continue
d'EDF madame la ministre il vous revient
aujourd'hui de le relancer
ce texte que nous allons étudier est
nécessaire car il est urgent d'agir pour
relancer notre filière nucléaire et ce
texte comporte deux grands volets le
premier porte sur la simplification des
procédures réglementaires et
administratives dit à la construction de
nouvelles installations nucléaires à
proximité des sites existants le second
à trait aux fonctionnements des
installations et ce projet de loi donc
pose le cadre d'une accélération
procédureale je veux saluer à cet
instant le travail de précision effectué
par la commission des affaires
économiques sur ce sur ce texte
initialement très technique et le
travail de son rapporteur Daniel
grimillet que nous dont nous connaissons
à la fois la compétence et dans son
engagement majeur et constant sur ce
sujet ce projet de loi n'est qu'une
étape avant le projet de loi majeur la
loi donc énergie climat en courant de
l'année 2023 je me fais des sites tout
particulièrement de la suppression de
l'objectif de réduction de 50% du
nucléaire dans le mix énergétique
que notre commission introduit dans ce
texte et que mon groupe apporté au
travers plusieurs amendements je pense
permettez-moi quand même de le dire à
cet instant en 2016 à Ségolène Royal qui
portait l'objectif de baisser de 75 à 50
% la part du nucléaire horizon 2025 nous
sommes en 2023 une orfèvre en matière de
dépl planification énergétique quelle
absence de realisme et qu'elle manque de
vision ce texte renforce aujourd'hui
utilement la place des collectivités
territoriales à ce titre je salue
particulièrement l'amendement qui tend à
exclure les nouveaux réacteurs du
décompte du zan au regard donc de
l'ampleur des projets il s'agit d'une
mesure protectrice pour nos
collectivités malgré toutes ces
aventures c'est notable chemin reste
encore très long devrait défis de le
vrai défi de demain sera technologique
industrielle financier et bien sûr
humain la filière doit retrouver
absolument son attractivité la montée en
compétences et la main d'oeuvre est l'un
des principaux défis de la relance du
nous devons absolument porter une vision
de long terme qui me permettra de rendre
attractive cette filière d'excellence
dans les 10 ans à venir c'est entre 10
et 15000 recrutements sont prévus donc
dans la filière nucléaire EDF prévoit
quant à elle le recrutement de 8 à 9000
personnes sur la période 2022 2023 pour
assurer cette relance le nucléaire porte
le triple objectif de souveraineté
énergétique indépendance de notre nation
et des durs carbonation de notre mode de
vie nous devons néanmoins apprendre de
nos échecs de nos échecs passés le père
de Flamanville l'abandon du projet
superhénix Astrid ou encore l'arrêt de
Fessenheim et en tirer tous les
enseignements enfin permettez-moi de
maîtriser en tant que conseiller
régional du Grand est sénateur de la
Meuse car notre département Cher Gérard
Longuet avec le département de
Haute-Marne accueille le projet Cigéo de
stockage des déchets nucléaires français
je vous sais madame la ministre
particulièrement engagé sur ce dossier
ce projet assis sur un travail du
laboratoire expérimental d'un
laboratoire expérimental vise à
sécuriser durable les déchets le
concours pleinement à la crédibilité à
l'acceptation au travers une maîtrise
totale de la filière gage de cette
crédibilité le projet s'inscrit dans un
temps long et laisse la porte ouverte
aux innovations futures cela doit nous
inspirer madame la ministre le seul
chemin reste encore long et les défis
très nombreux cependant ces derniers
résultats sur la fusion sont très
encourageants ce texte constitue une
première étape pour la relance du
nucléaire qui est absolument nécessaire
car elle conditionne notre avenir
industriel économique et social fort de
ces constats et prêt à prendre toute sa
part dans ce nouveau débat le groupe Les
Indépendants votre en faveur de ce texte
merci la parole est à Monsieur Ronan
Dantec pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur les reporteurs madame la
Présidente il était une fois il était
une fois le nucléaire français j'ai un
peu hésité sur la qualification de cette
aventure industrielle unique au monde
épopée odyssée finalement conte de fées
me semble correspondre le mieux dans
cette histoire fait appel aux
merveilleux merveille technologique
merveille économique et chapitre plus
récent sous les augures du Mas joncovici
merveille écologique
tout est dit mais mais il y a des petits
mais les vrais amateurs de compte le
savent de Charles Perrault frère Grimm
la fin du compte est souvent tragique et
ne termine pas toujours comme un dessin
animé de Walt Disney la faillite
retentissante et malheureuse
illustration dans notre compte de fées
nucléaire français merveille
technologique certes mais concernant
notre nucléaire à nous quelque part sans
cravité juste des corrosion de tuyaux
des circuits de refroidissement
aboutissent quand même à ce que
l'intermittence de notre parc nucléaire
est supérieur l'année dernière à
l'intermittence du grand éolien danois
peu importe je vous l'accorde tout cela
est du passé car de la brume normande
surgit le PF flambant neuf de
Flamanville dans les électrons se
déversent déjà en masse sur l'ouest
breton
on m'informe qu'une vilaine sorcière mal
intentionnée Dominique voignet peut-être
la transformer en Belle au bois dormant
mais je sais aussi que dans l'hémicycle
se trouve de valeureux guerrier prêt à
traverser les Landes du Cotentin pour
réveiller la belle endormie et par
ailleurs pas d'inquiétude je suis en
mesure de vous informer aujourd'hui que
nos ingénieurs français avaient
découvert avant tout le monde la formule
du béton du Forum romain un des secrets
les mieux gardés de l'antiquité ce qui
nous rend quand même optimiste sur le
fait que même si le combustible est
chargé que dans un siècle notre enceinte
en béton sera toujours vaillante
merveille économique ensuite à ce niveau
nous n'avons pas de concurrence en
pétrez dans un dogme libéral sur un nez
avec des calculs de courte vue sur les
prix de revient du mégawattheure aucun
aucun
de nos voisins n'est capable de financer
pendant autant d'années une machine qui
ne marche jamais mais qui pour reprendre
les mots de l'ancien PG PDG d'EDF Henri
Proglio était la seule dont on a
retrouvé les plans dans un placard vu
les difficultés à les déchiffrer ils
étaient d'ailleurs peut-être en latin
comme le béton du forum nous allons
battre et nous pouvons en être fiers le
génie français le record du monde du
prix le plus élevé du mégawater produit
par une machinerie industrielle de
production électrique et comme nous
sommes têtus nous nous projetons dans un
monde en circuit fermé ou vers 2040 un
EPR de produira des kilow à deux trois
quatre fois le prix de nos voisins
européens enfermés dans leur sortilèges
de NR sommes-nous encore dans un conte
de fée ou dans une fable j'hésite mais
son père le filter de mon propos et
verser dans une sécheresse
technocratique qui ne me siege il y a
quand même aujourd'hui du photovoltaïque
produit à moins de 40 euros le
mégawattheure un peu partout là où nous
avons vendu surplomb à nos amis anglais
de l'EPR qui produira à plus de 120
euros le mégawatt
reste donc reste donc la merveille
écologique que nul ne peut contester une
production décarbonée et infinie
enfin ce qui est infini c'est surtout la
durée de vie des déchets sur lesquels
nous n'avons toujours pas de solution à
part creuser des trous pourtant si vous
reprenez les temps anciens ils ont été
cités et rêvé des temps du pompidolyse
du plan Messmer et du consensus
les bonnes fées de l'époque nous avez
alors certifié que nous trouverions la
solution pour les déchets en cours de
route grâce au génie de nos ingénieurs
mais ce Rane de Bretagne ne voit
toujours rien venir à Brennilis ou
l'enveloppe du coeur n'est toujours pas
été percée à l'inverse du reliquaire
heureusement Catherine Deneuve n'a pas
encore eu la peau de l'âne qui finance
le budget de l'État car le démantèlement
de nos vieilles centrales mais je le
rappelle toujours pas financé
il se fait tard je vois l'heure qui
avance avant que la présidente ne me
transforme en citrouille je recherche
donc mes pantoufles de verre V e r T et
vous donne rendez-vous pour deux jours
de débat passionnant pour enfin
comprendre les raisons de cette
précipitation
mal utilisé je le souligne les bottes de
ces lieux peuvent faire très bûcher
merci
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Bernard Guy pour le groupe rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendants pour 6 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame dans la présidente des
commissions des affaires économiques
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues en ce début d'année 2023 notre
parc nucléaire reprend des forces après
une production nucléaire en 2022
historiquement faible autour de 280
tirawatts nous devrions atteindre cette
année 330 térats
deux facteurs expliquent principalement
cette faible disponibilité du nucléaire
les opérations de maintenance classique
et surtout un problème de fissuration
dit de corrosion sous contrainte ce mal
mystérieux qui menace des tuyauteries de
secours destinés au refroidissement
résultat ce sont les trains les plus
récentes et les plus puissantes qui sont
impactées si vous Parly et la centrale
de choses
sur ce point cette crise ponctuelle nous
a permis de constater l'efficacité des
autorités de contrôle et la diligence
DDF à garantir un niveau de sécurité
optimal le problème générique sur les
réacteurs a été pris très au sérieux et
sur les 10 chantiers ouverts 6 sont
désormais terminés ainsi en ce milieu
d'hiver seul 12 réacteurs sont à
l'arrêts contre plus de 30 sorti de
l'été le pire est donc passé lorsque
l'on sait que le pays a dû se résoudre
en 2022 a importé plus d'électricité
qu'il n'en a exporté une première depuis
40 ans
une année difficile pour le parc
nucléaire qui doit nous interroger sur
ce que nous souhaitons pour assurer
notre indépendance énergétique face aux
dérèglement climatique je rappelle que
l'année 2022 a été la plus chaude jamais
mesurée en France afin d'assurer une
sécurité d'approvisionnement ce
gouvernement a choisi de construire sa
stratégie énergétique autour de deux
axes les énergies renouvelables et
l'énergie nucléaire par conséquent notre
groupe se réjouit que ce gouvernement
est choisi de reprendre le fil de la
grande aventure du nucléaire civil en
France avec la construction de 6 EPR 2
et le lancement d'études sur la
construction de 8pr 2 additionnels mais
une fois ce cadre politique posé vient
le temps essentiel de la concertation
un mouvement un mouvement démocratique
indispensable pour recueillir la vie des
citoyens sur les orientations de la
politique énergétique française et
permettre à chacune et chacun de
s'exprimer sur les mesures à mettre en
oeuvre pour atteindre des objectifs de
transition énergétique une concertation
nationale qui a débuté le 20 octobre et
qui prendra fin demain le 18 janvier
c'est à partir de ces contributions que
le Parlement pourra à son tour débattre
de la loi de programmation sur l'énergie
et le climat en l'occurrence notre
groupe dépendra une politique conforme à
l'accord de Paris basée sur une
réduction des émissions nettes de gaz à
effet de serre à -55% en 2030 par
rapport au niveau de 1990
en attendant plutôt que d'être dans la
passivité notre gouvernement a choisi
d'agir et d'accélérer nous nous en
félicitons c'est l'objet du texte que
nous allons examiner axé sur des mesures
de simplification administrative tant
sur les questions d'urbanisme que de
procédures de planification ou de
simplification dans le seul but de
gagner du temps du moins de ne plus en
perdre ainsi dès la promulgation de la
loi de programmation les mesures sur
lesquelles nous allons débattre
permettrait d'être opérationnel en vue
de la construction d'une première paire
de réacteurs EPR 2 à Paris de deux
autres aggravelines dans le Nord et
comme élu de moi rejoint par mon ami le
maire de Pierrelatte Alain galluc nous
avons additionné en commission
je souhaite ardemment que le site du
Tricastin puisse accueillir de nouveaux
réacteurs ce sont 135 hectares qui sont
d'ores et déjà disponibles pour donner
une nouvelle impulsion économique
industrielle à notre région ce projet de
loi certes très technique contiennent
néanmoins des mesures de simplification
indispensables si nous voulons
rapidement mettre en œuvre notre
stratégie nucléaire parmi les mesures
phares le texte propose de dispenser de
permis de construire les installations
et travaux portant sur la création d'un
réacteur nucléaire la construction de
réacteurs électronucléaires induit en
effet des contraintes que le permis de
construire ne permet pas d'appréhender
dans leur intégralité le projet de loi
permet aussi de démarrer certains
travaux dès l'obtention d'une
autorisation environnementale j'entends
par là des activités qui ne revêtent
aucun caractère sensible comme les
travaux terrassement ou de construction
de bureau clôtures et parking nécessaire
au chantier
concernant la centrale de Penly il est
proposé de construire des nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires en bord de mer en
effet la particularité de cette centrale
proviennent sa construction établie au
pied des hautes falaises de craies de la
Côte d'Albâtre l'application de la loi
littorale doit donc être écarté pour ses
constructions enfin le texte supprime à
juste titre la mise à l'arrêt définitive
de plein droit d'une installation
nucléaire de base ayant cessé de
fonctionner depuis plus de deux ans
l'actualité récente nous a montré que
certaines centrales frappées par une
longue mise à l'arrêt ont dû recourir à
des dossiers de demande de dérogation
chronophage et peu utile ces mesures de
simplification ont été globalement
approuvées par la commission des
affaires économiques dont je salue
l'esprit de responsabilité notre groupe
proposera cependant quelques amendements
de correction visant à revenir sur des
précisions adoptées en commission qui
s'avère être satisfaites par le code de
l'environnement
je fais également référence à l'article
3 concernant des précisions apportées
aux demandes d'autorisation
environnementale dont l'écriture
actuelle pourrait alourdir le dispositif
sans apporter de réels plus-value
hormis ces quelques modifications nous
nous félicitons qu'une grande partie des
groupes politiques soutiennent ce texte
fondateur première pierre d'un immense
chantier pour la relance du nucléaire en
France et bien évidemment notre groupe
politique votera ce projet de loi je
vous remercie merci la parole est à
Monsieur Franco montoger pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues parce que le Président
de la République et les gouvernements
qui se sont succédés depuis 2017 l'ont
voulu ainsi la question énergétique a
été complètement absente du débat public
pendant les 5 dernières années vous
n'avez pas voulu aborder au fond cette
question déterminante pour l'avenir de
notre pays et ce n'est pas faute de vous
avoir souvent interpellé à ce sujet
pourtant les raisons ne manquaient pas
toutes liées à la question du changement
climatique et à l'action immédiate qui
en découle sous forme de politique
publique à construire dans la
concertation et la compréhension de nos
concitoyens à propos de souveraineté
économiques et de compétitivité de coûts
de l'énergie pour de très nombreux
Français en difficulté d'électrification
pour la décarbonation des process
industriels d'adaptation des modes de
transport de l'habitat etc et bien
entendu à propos de l'inflation puisque
l'énergie est au cœur de ce mécanisme
avant l’envoler des prix de l'énergie
liée à la crise géopolitique en Europe
une crise de l'offre était déjà là que
vous n'avez pas voulu prendre en compte
depuis trop longtemps l'entreprise
nationale EDF est aussi ponctionnée par
la reine qui la place aujourd'hui dans
une position presque inextriqueable là
aussi vous êtes restés sourd aux appels
de son PDG que vous aviez nommé le
quinquennat aurait dû être mis à profit
pour engager la concertation avec les
Français et le Parlement sur la
stratégie énergétique climat
et préalable à la loi de programmation
quinquennale et à la PPE qui en est la
traduction opérationnelle cinq ans de
perdues et en février 2022 de manière
quasi concomitante au début de la guerre
en Ukraine l'annonce du lancement de
trois paires de PR2 et pour plus tard de
8pr supplémentaires l'annonce aussi de
quelques gigawatts de SMS dont on ne
sait pas au-delà des incertitudes sur la
technologie quelle sera la doctrine
d'utilisation voulez-vous laisser ce
type de technologie filer madame la
ministre aux mains du privé la question
n'est pas légère et je pense que le
Parlement français et les Français ont
leur mot à dire alors aujourd'hui en
position de faiblesse et dans le cadre
d'une logique qui défie le bon sens vous
nous demandez d'accélérer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
et vous nous proposez de simplifier pour
les 15 ans à venir les procédures
automobilisant la construction de
nouvelles installations nucléaires sur
site existant ou à proximité immédiate
ce que vous proposez permettra de gagner
une année voire deux après avoir perdu 5
et pour des installations industrielles
dont la durée de vie pourrait être de 60
ans ou plus dit comme ça on saisit mieux
l'enjeu qui pour naître pas du tout à la
hauteur du sujet et de son urgence
nationale n'en est pas moins à
considérer nous sommes globalement
favorables à ces dispositions de
simplification qui faciliteront le
travail des opérateurs EDF production
RTE et les filières industrielles
concernées mais madame la ministre où le
président et le gouvernement veulent-ils
amener le pays en matière de mix
énergétique tous les réacteurs
nucléaires anciens ne pourront pas être
reconduit certains devont être mis à
l'arrêt à la demande de l'ASN RTE là
anticipé dans ces hypothèses d'études
dès lors se pose la question et je vous
la pose madame du scénario dans le cas
de duquel le président la République
annonce la construction de 14 EPR 2 le
scénario n03 de l'étude future
énergétique 2050 de RTE et celui dont la
proportion d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire est la plus élevée à 50%.
est-ce celui que vous retenez quand je
vois que dans votre amendement donc nous
allons discuter dans quelques instants
vous parlez de mix équilibré par contre
et pour être cohérent avec l'exigence de
débat public et parlementaire préalable
à la loi de programmation quinquennale
et à la PPE nous ne sommes pas
favorables quand je dis nous c'est mon
groupe au dispositions introduites par
le rapporteur en commission
nous proposerons des amendements de
suppression parce que la PPE ne peut pas
être traitée sur un coin de table au
détour d'un texte centré sur les
procédures
et si vous pensez que ces objectifs de
PPE sont en rapport avec le texte
proposé par le gouvernement alors
pourquoi nous avons refusé la mandement
sur EDF dont le rapport avec le sujet
est évident tout en considérant comme
utile le texte au périmètre initial
notre vote finale sera orienté par le
sort qui sera réservé à nos amendements
de suppression des seuils légaux actuels
et parce qu'ils ne doit pas y avoir
d'articles 45 à géométrie politique
variable nous rappellerons que la loi
doit garantir à EDF un caractère public
d'entreprises intégrées au cœur du futur
énergétique de la nation je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Fabien gay pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues août 2022 par un
projet de loi sur le pouvoir d'achat le
gouvernement sécurise le Revel le
relèvement du plafond de la reine à 120
Tera watts
2022 arrive le projet de loi de finances
le gouvernement prolonge le bouclier
tarifaire pour 2023 décembre 2022 examen
un projet de loi du gouvernement sur les
EnR et janvier 2023 encore un texte sur
l'énergie cette fois-ci pour construire
de nouvelles centrales nucléaires texte
à peptexte la question de l'énergie est
traitée segment par segment petit
morceau par petit morceau difficile d'y
voir une cohérence ou une réflexion dans
l'ensemble le sentiment qui prévaut
c'est plutôt celui d'un traitement sur
la forme qui évite toujours les
questions de faux qu'il s'agisse des
énergies renouvelables du nucléaire la
faute serait toujours la même
les procédures administratives trop
longues qu'il faudrait simplifier la
même recette se glisse dans tous les
textes saupoudrer d'un peu
d'acceptabilité et de quelques mots
magiques concertation démocratie locale
discussion des points évidemment très
importants qui doivent être parti
intégrante de la mise en pratique d'un
texte mais pour qu'il y ait une mise en
pratique encore faut-il qu'on sache vers
quel objectif on avance et dans votre
texte il n'y a pas d'objectif clair et
défini car madame la ministre c'est une
chose de viser la construction de
nouveaux EPR mais comment rien n'est dit
sur le financement de ces nouveaux
équipements votre texte n'en parle tout
simplement pas qui va payer pour ses
investissements EDF et c'est 60
milliards de dettes dont une bonne
partie vient de la reine
ce système absurde qu'il a ruiné d'année
après année au profit des alternatives
qui n'ont eux rien investi et qui va
bénéficier de ces nouvelles capacités de
production les alternatives encore le
mécanisme de la reine va arriver à son
terme dans deux ans mais qu'est-ce qui
va prendre la suite à chaque fois qu'on
pose la question vous nous faites la
même réponse les discussions sont en
cours ça veut bien dire que ça veut dire
on réfléchit à créer des équipements à
investir avant même de savoir comment on
va exploiter la production rien ne
justifie que l'État s'abstient d'une
telle réflexion et pourtant silence
radio dans votre texte pas un mot
ensuite autre point central pourquoi la
France construire-t-elle de nouveaux
réacteurs pour sa souveraineté
énergétique pour son indépendance pardon
mais il n'y a aucune souveraineté
possible avec le marché européen
l'énergie vous payez pour la politique
énergétique de vos voisins qu'il cherche
à ou non des énergies fossiles alors à
moins de réformer le marché européen de
l'énergie vous pouvez construire tous
les réacteurs du monde vous n'aurez
aucune souveraineté mais là encore vous
allez me dire pour la réforme du marché
européen les discussions se rendent en
cours rebelote on part sur un texte à
l'aveugle sur des investissements à
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
mais sans savoir ce qu'il y aura après
c'est la politique du allons-y et on
verra plus tard même chose pour EDF
l'État veut détenir 100% du capital très
bien mais pourquoi faire un grand
service public de l'énergie comme nous
le souhaitons ou scinder l'entreprise
historique en plusieurs morceaux et
l'ouvrir aux acteurs du chapitre privé
mystère on ne sait toujours pas mais il
faudrait voter un texte pour construire
de nouveaux réacteurs le tout alors que
même le nouveau PDG d'EDF n'a pas encore
défini sa feuille de route c'est-à-dire
que nous n'avons même pas de visibilité
sur l'existant sur sa gestion sur ses
ambitions
même pas encore de PPE vous nous
demandez nous nous projeter sur de
nouvelles infrastructures mais quid de
l'arrêt des 12 tranches prévues dans la
PPE donc non madame la ministre la
question ici ce n'est pas la longueur
des procédures administratives c'est de
savoir vers quoi nous avançons pour le
prochain siècle parce que nous parlons
de 25 ans de constructions pour une
durée de vie de 60 ans l'urgence n'est
donc pas de réduire de quelques mois les
procédures administratives sur des
chantiers qui commenceront au mieux en
2027 mais bien d'avoir un débat
politique et une vision de long terme
d'ailleurs dernière question qui va
travailler sur les chantiers des
nouveaux réacteurs qui va les entretenir
et quelle filière industrielle parce
qu'à chaque fois que vous avez
l'occasion vous sonnez la charge contre
le statut des IOG cette fois-ci avec une
réforme des retraites à laquelle 80% des
Français sont opposés vous attaquez au
régime spécial des IEG c'est vous
attaquez à toute la filière et c'est lui
faire perdre de l'attractivité
comment vous allez construire des
réacteurs sans travailleurs et
travailleuses qualifiés si vous comptez
sur dans la sous-traitance en cascade
alors il faudra assumer que vous voulez
du nucléaire low cost et bas de gamme et
des travailleurs précaires qu'il a
encore subiront votre réforme des
retraites et c'est incompatible avec les
enjeux de sûreté nucléaire votre texte
c'est parler du nucléaire mais sans
parler du nucléaire donc pour nous ça
sera l'abstention je vous remercie merci
chers collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Pierre Moga pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 4 minutes
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
économique messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues
attendus depuis plusieurs mois si ce
n'est amené
la mise à l'agenda parlementaire de
l'accélération de notre stratégie
nucléaire bien que tardive est à saluer
l'atome doit être au cœur de notre
politique énergétique plus qu'une
conviction c'est une certitude
bienvenue et salutaire ce projet de loi
ne résout
qu'une partie de l'équation posée par
nos politiques énergétiques avec mes
collègues du groupe centriste nous
regrettons ainsi le désordre inhérent à
l'examen parlementaire de notre
politique énergétique
en décembre nous examinions la loi
d'accélération des endr aujourd'hui
c'est le nucléaire et en juin dans le
meilleur des cas ce sera la
programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie
mes chers collègues tout cela manque de
lisibilité et de clarté nous devons
pourtant poser les jalons d'une
politique cohérente afin de bâtir notre
souveraineté énergétique à l'horizon 250
conçu comme accélérateur ce texte
simplifie tant les procédures juridiques
induite par la construction de 14
futures réacteurs annoncés par le
Président de la République lors de son
discours de Belfort que les contraintes
pesant sur les sites existants
ils visent à diminuer les freins à lever
les blocages et à contourner les
obstacles conduits conduisant
aujourd'hui à condamner la construction
des réacteurs et la modernisation des
installations à une lenteur aussi
désolante que problématique
si le texte initial du gouvernement
aller dans le bon sens je souhaite
saluer le travail précieux des
rapporteurs Daniel Gremillet et Pascal
Martin ainsi que celui de la commission
des affaires économiques et de la
commission du développement durable
ils ont rappelé tout l'intérêt du
travail parlementaire chers collègues je
souhaite que l'examen en séance publique
nous permettent de continuer d'enrichir
le texte
à l'heure de la crise de l'énergie il
est de notre responsabilité de bâtir
notre souveraineté en s'appuyant sur un
mix énergétique décarbonée
associant à la fois énergie nucléaire
pilotable et énergies renouvelable
désormais compétitive
l'un n'ira pas sans l'autre
afin de bâtir une politique énergétique
à la hauteur des défis qui nous
attendent
c'est afin de relever ces défis qu'avec
mes collègues du groupe de l'Union
centriste nous proposerons un certain
nombre d'abandonnements et nous voterons
ce texte avec exigences et
responsabilité
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane
piennois pour le groupe les républicains
pour 6 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
en intervenant en 13ème position dans
cette discussion générale notamment
après les excellents rapporteurs
d'années grébiers et Pascal Martin j'ai
bien conscience que tout ou presque a
été dit sur ce texte mais je vais tenter
d'apporter un regard peut-être un peu
moins technique et plus pratiquant
pratique si j'ose dire mes premiers mots
seront pour le titre de ce projet de loi
censé traduire les intentions du
Gouvernement vous me permettrez en tant
que membre de la culture d'en faire une
présentation quelque peu iconoclastes
sans doute grâce à plusieurs références
culturelles bien connues du grand public
de manière à refléter le sentiment assez
largement partagé
s'il fallait trouver un titre qui
correspondent précisément aux objectifs
affichés j'opterais volontiers pour
l'oeuvre de Marcel Proust à la recherche
du temps perdu
c'est en effet parce que l'exécutif
procrastine depuis 10 ans sur la
question du nucléaire que nous devons en
catastrophe envisager les voix et moyen
d'accélérer pour permettre de renouveler
notre parc de réacteurs nucléaire
mais dans cette assemblée chacun sait
que le temps perdu ne se rattrape pas et
je rappelle que Proust a mis 16 ans pour
écrire cette oeuvre complète
ma deuxième référence dans le registre
pictural cette fois et le Radeau de la
Méduse tant la gestion de la politique
énergétique dans notre pays est un
naufrage dont les récentes tentatives de
sauvetage relèvent davantage de la
panique générale que d'un plan bien
établi
troisième référence la chanson de Dalida
paroles paroles particulièrement
approprié pour décrire les déclarations
successives du président Macron depuis
deux ans à grand renfort de
communication mais qu'aucune décision
concrète n'est venue traduire de manière
formelle à ce jour
enfin le populaire film La vérité si je
mens synthétise bien les atermoiements
que nous observons depuis 2017 et
notamment la valse des ministres qui se
sont succédés au ministère de la
transition écologique et énergétique
capable de dire tout et le contraire de
tout dans un laps de temps assez réduit
le bilan du président Macron est lourd
de pas en arrière avec la fermeture
effective de deux réacteurs de
Fessenheim un bon dans le passé avec
l'arrêt du programme de recherche Astrid
sur les réacteurs de quatrième
génération et aujourd'hui donc un tout
petit pas en avant avec ce texte aux
promesses bien tenues essentiellement
pour réduire des formalités
administratives
madame la ministre le propos peut
paraître quelque peu acide mais il est
temps de prendre vraiment des positions
qui engagent de nouveau notre pays
pardon sur la voie d'une souveraineté
que d'autres le général de Gaulle et le
président Pompidou en tête on suit
patiemment construire avec la
réalisation de notre parc
électronucléaire en moins de 20 ans
une doxa depuis une doxa idéologique
c'est progressivement imposée dans le
débat public national appuyé par une
communication il faut le dire assez
efficace je prends un exemple assez
significatif qui concerne la soi-disant
durée de vie de nos réacteurs qui
auraient été fixé à 40 ans dès l'origine
une forme d'obsolescence programmée
avant l'heure il s'agit bien évidemment
d'une légende urbaine couramment reprise
jusqu'au plus haut niveau de l'État dont
le sol objectif est de discréter la
filière
encore plus fort nous sommes aujourd'hui
en infraction par rapport à notre propre
législation qui prévoit depuis 2006 la
fermeture du cycle du combustible que
seuls les réacteurs à neutrons rapides
permettent divisé par 10 la quantité de
déchets produits limiter la
prolifération de plutonium pouvoir
utiliser les 300000 tomes d'uranium
appauvril qui sont sur notre sol assurer
la production d'électricité pour plus de
1000 ans la promesse d'un nucléaire
durable était trop belle et trop
tangible pour qu'elle pour que quelques
idéologues ne nous empêchent habilement
d'y accéder
on ne dira jamais assez à quel point
l'arrêt du programme Astrid en 2019 a
des conséquences désastreuses que j'ai
eu l'occasion de recenser dans un
rapport de l'OPEX qu'aux produits en
de plus au moment même où la demande
était sur une tendance haussière
incontestable et certainement durable
notre pays a choisi de réduire ses
moyens d'y répondre de manière
opérationnelle pour être encore plus
clair nous avons accepté un tas de
mesure louable au demeurant visant à
mettre fin au recours aux énergies
fossiles mais sans aucune mesure
anticipatrice anticipant pardon la
tension induite sur la demande en
électricité pire les décisions visant
depuis 25 ans a condamné la production
d'origine nucléaire sur l'hôtel de
petits arrangements politiciens nous ont
conduit dans une impasse au bout de cet
impasse nos gouvernements découvrent
qu'il y a un mur celui de
l'approvisionnement conduisant à des
risques de délestage ce terme élégant et
diplomatique pour parler d'éventuelles
coupures de courant au pays des Lumières
notre destin énergétique est désormais
entre les mains du gouvernement de
l'ombre qui tentent de gérer la pénurie
qui l'a lui-même organisé
pour citer Bossuet Dieu serait des
hommes qui déplorent les effets dont ils
chérissent les causes
je salue pour terminer l'excellent
travail de nos rapporteurs travail
extrêmement approfondi pour pousser le
curseur aussi loin que possible de
manière à affirmer clairement de
nouvelles ambitions pour notre pays mais
madame la ministre vos déclarations
récentes laissent assez peu d'espoir sur
une position définitive favorable du
gouvernement par rapport au grand
principe plusieurs fois évoqué dans ce
débat revenir sur le plafond des 50% du
nucléaire dans notre mix électrique
prolongé avec la vie de la SN les
réacteurs mis sur la liste funeste des
fermetures programmées supprimer le
plafond des 63 gigawatts de potentiel
nucléaire dans ce contexte vous savez
bien qu'au-delà de ce texte vous
engagements la ministre seront très
attendus et croyez bien que nous étions
très attentifs je vous remercie
si chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Gilbert Luc de naze pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 4 minutes
la présidente madame la ministre notre
vigilance est aujourd'hui appelée sur ce
texte technique relatif à l'accélération
du nucléaire français il constitue le
deuxième volet d'accélération après
celui des énergies renouvelables comme
pour le premier le même questionnement
se pose sur la méthode alors qu'un grand
débat
sur la loi structurante de stratégie
énergétique devrait être examinée par le
Parlement au second trimestre semestre
2023 nous nous lançons nous avançons et
nous demandons je me demande j'ai pas
bien compris madame ici qu'on mettait
pas la charrue avant les bœufs autrement
dit on accélère des choix que nous
ajusterons plus tard c'est comme si un
médecin presque qui va l'ordonnance
avant d'avoir examiné son patient d'un
point de vue de l'aménagement du
territoire complété des installations
nucléaires ou créer de nouveaux EPERS
n'est pas neutre
ces constructions ces constructions
peuvent être pensés sans concertation
dans un débat de techniciens comme dans
les années 70 ou penser comme les
politiques publiques d'aménagement avec
consultation et transparence vis-à-vis
des citoyens pour favoriser
l'acceptabilité des projets en outre ces
projets prévus pour fonctionner à partir
2035 2040 vont être examinés sur le plan
environnemental climatique sur le plan
d'iris sur le plan hydrométrique sur le
retrait de côte etc avec des données de
2023 regardez les phénomènes passés pour
en déduire des projections et désormais
impossibles il faut s'inscrire dans
l'incertitude des aléas climatiques
l'accès de l'acceptabilité sociétale du
nucléaire suppose de la transparence et
de la concertation avec toutes les
parties prenantes
elle suppose aussi une évaluation
démocratique et pluraliste des besoins
de notre société en matière énergétique
dans un contexte de transition et de
décarbonation de nos économies si ce
texte vise à accélérer les procédures
pour un amorcer la relance de la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires il ne devrait en aucun cas
servir de support à anticiper la future
grande loi qui définira la stratégie
française au long cours relative à
l'énergie au climat et à la composition
à la composition de notre mixte
énergétique d'autant plus que des
concertations sont en cours nous avons
donc sur ce texte était vigilant sur
plusieurs points et trois éléments
essentiels le premier conserver le
caractère exceptionnel des mesures
d'accélération et de simplification tout
en les limitant raisonnablement dans le
temps le deuxième mieux qualifié les
prescriptions de l'Agence de sûreté
nucléaire et compliqué davantage le
Parlement le troisième prendre en compte
l'incertitude climatique dans laquelle
vont fonctionner ces nouvelles
installations la construction de 6 EPR
qui seront encore en fonction à
l'horizon 2080 2090 doivent évaluer les
conditions climatiques locales dans
lesquelles ils vont fonctionner il
s'agit notamment de mettre en oeuvre des
études de descente d'échelle dynamique
absolument nécessaire en plus des
éléments de projection globale du GIEC
enfin le nucléaire n'est pas seulement
une question de norme il s'agit de
donner du sens à ceux qui auront un
réacteur près de chez eux au futur
personnels qui vont construire ces
équipements aux ingénieurs chargés de la
sûreté de ces équipements aux élus et à
tous les électeurs qui vont enfin afin
de mettre en évidence le sens profond
des actions menées qui manquent
aujourd'hui à beaucoup de citoyens
l'énergie nucléaire est donc un défi
et humains autant que technique
procédurale et financier
tes chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane demie pour le groupe
Union centriste pour 4 minutes
madame la Présidente
madame la ministre madame la Présidente
de commission messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues le projet de loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui à pour
objectif de faciliter le développement
de l'énergie nucléaire au travers de la
construction de nouvelles installations
la stratégie énergétique de la France
n'a pas toujours été celle du nucléaire
en témoigne la fermeture de la centrale
de Fessenheim en 2020 et celles
annonçaient en 2018 de 14 réacteurs
d'ici 2035
en témoigne aussi les propos d'une
ancienne ministre de la transition
écologique et numéro 2 du gouvernement
qui jugé en 2018 je la cite absurde la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires et qui affirmait promptement
je la cite toujours ne pas voir le
nucléaire comme une énergie d'avenir
l'État ont donc changé mais comme disait
Edgar fort sans référence à l'énergie
éolienne d'ailleurs ce n'est pas la
girouette qui tourne c'est le vent et
effectivement la météo géopolitique
dorénavant plus imprévisible que la
météo climatique nous contrainte à faire
évoluer nos logiciels politiques nous
avions un logiciel binaire qui
finalement opposé le nucléaire au
renouvelable considérant que l'un devait
progresser au détriment de l'autre
nécessité faisant loi on change de
paradigme avec la conviction nouvelle
que ce n'est pas l'un ou l'autre mais
bel et bien l'un et l'autre Sophie prima
d'ailleurs dans son intervention l'a
très bien signalé piéger par ce
pseudo-dogme qui s'est traduit par des
volts face nous avons perdu beaucoup de
temps car après avoir facilité la
destruction nous facilitons dorénavant
la construction
le nucléaire qui n'est pas exempt de
défaut présente d'indéniable réponse aux
problèmes climatogéopolitique du moment
il est décarboné sa capacité de
production est modulable et adaptable
aux besoins de la population et surtout
il est synonyme d'indépendance
énergétique et donc diplomatique et donc
politique
la recherche gomme au fur et à mesure
d'ailleurs les défauts de cette
technologie les récentes des converses
scientifiques californiennes dans le
domaine de la fusion nucléaire et tous
spécifiquement la capacité à franchir le
seuil d'inition c'est à dire la phase où
les réacteurs produisent davantage
d'énergie qu'il n'en consomment sont
particulièrement prometteuses certes il
faudra beaucoup de temps mais à
l'évidence les innovations attendues
nous amèneront pour probablement
apporter un autre regard sur ce mode
énergétique
ce projet de loi permet donc d'accélérer
la construction de nouveaux réacteurs en
France d'une part en simplifiant les
différentes procédures urbanistiques ou
environnementales et d'autre part en
clarifiant les modalités de réexamen
périodique des réacteurs de plus de 35
ans c'est un premier pas l'article
premier délimitant le champ
d'application de ce texte au
construction jouxtant les parcs
nucléaires existants comme PANI près de
Dieppe que j'ai d'ailleurs pu visiter
avec notre collègue et rapporteur Pascal
Martin
l'avenir plus difficile à prévoir que le
passé comme dirait Woody Allen nous
imposera probablement d'élargir le champ
des possibles avec la construction de
petits réacteurs les fameux SMR capable
de fournir des solutions dans les sites
isolés nous l'avons compris cette
stratégie d'ensemble doit être pensée
sur le temps long comme cela a
d'ailleurs été rappelé en commission et
elle devra englober à la fois l'amour
avec l'approvisionnement en combustible
et les ressources en uranium et
naturellement à Laval avec la nécessaire
question de la gestion des déchets nous
devons également soutenir la formation
le recrutement et la recherche dans le
domaine du nucléaire autrefois vu comme
une filiale une filière d'excellence le
nucléaire fait aujourd'hui face à une
réelle pénurie de talents
face au tergiversations politiques
effectivement nos jeunes ingénieurs et
techniciens se sont détournés depuis
longtemps du nucléaire lui préférant
d'autres industries plus pérennes ou
alors les cabinets de conseils il est
crucial de renforcer l'attractivité de
la filière la formation de personnels
qualifiées étant la clé d'une filière
industrielle solide c'est donc un grand
chantier national qui nécessite un
travail collectif un travail discipliné
et un travail transparent le pragmatisme
et la responsabilité de revendiquité
guidé nos choix politiques le groupe
centriste votera je dis de conclure
c'est pas trois phrases merci beaucoup
même la ministre c'est vous qui avez la
parole maintenant
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs je
voudrais d'abord revenir juste un
instant sur la question du calendrier je
trouve que par rapport à un certain
nombre d'interventions il y a une forme
de paradoxe à demander à avoir
immédiatement une loi sur la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
tout en mettant en exergue qu'il faut
respecter le débat public qui se déroule
maintenant
qu'il faut également que la réforme du
marché de l'électricité c'est vous
monsieur le sénateur gay qui l'indiqué
soit terminé elle se déroule maintenant
et qu'il faudrait disposer des
propositions du nouveau patron d'EDF sur
le financement et sur la manière plus
généralement de réguler ce programme
travail qu'il est en train de faire
maintenant vous m'accorderez donc qu'il
y a peut-être une confusion là encore
entre vitesse et précipitations nous
respectons le débat public et il est
très clair que je ne foulerai pas aux
pieds cette demande des Français de
participer à ce débat cette demande que
vous avez d'ailleurs votée pour me
précipiter et décider où vous faire
décider le mix énergétique que nous
devons avoir pour les prochaines années
ça tombe d'autant plus
de manière légitime que nous allons
parler de la programmation pluriel
annuelle de l'énergie des années 2024
2028 et effectivement avec une
perspective de long terme 2024 2028 sauf
erreur c'est l'année prochaine nous
faisons donc l'exercice dans le bon sens
et effectivement parce que nous prenons
nos responsabilités nous agissons en
temps masqué pour permettre d'améliorer
et d'anticiper les jalons administratifs
pour les décisions qui pourraient être
prises sur la production nucléaire et
pour accélérer de la production
d'énergie renouvelable puisque vous le
savez comment nous sommes déjà en retard
sur la production renouvelable des
années 2018-2023
l'exécutif procrastine depuis 5 ans
depuis 10 ans les versions sont
différentes en fonction de l'endroit on
se trouve sur l'hémicycle vous
m'accorderez qui lui fallut prendre une
décision en 2007 si on a vu voulu
disposer de réacteurs nucléaires
aujourd'hui je me permettrai pas de
mettre en cause qui que ce soit autour
de cette Mexique pour une petite raison
qui n'est pas complètement neutre en
2011 il y a eu d'abord en 2007 on était
très confortable en matière de
production électrique et nous n'étions
pas tout à fait dans le même sentiment
d'urgence sur le réchauffement
climatique par ailleurs en 2011 il y a
eu un accident qui a marqué tous les
esprits qui est l'accident de Fukushima
chacun ses positionné plus ou moins en
retrait par rapport au nucléaire mais
j'invite chacun à faire preuve de ne pas
reconstituer
à posteriori le passé ça a jeté un coup
de froid on peut se le dire sur la
question de la filière nucléaire et
aujourd'hui certains groupes qui sont
plus présent d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée
nationale qui s'y porte en bandoulière
leur soutien au nucléaire il se trouve
qu'à l'époque ils étaient contre le
nucléaire je me permettrai pas de
rentrer dans le détail des groupes ici
s'agissant de
l'acceptabilité
locale et nationale monsieur le
rapporteur Martin vous avez dit des
choses qui me paraissent effectivement
très importantes l'acceptabilité locale
et nationale elle suppose d'aller
jusqu'au bout du débat engagé sous les
sites de la Commission nationale du
débat public c'est ce que nous faisons
en suivant vos précieux conseils vous
indiquez également que la réussite du
programme va dépendre de facteurs qui ne
sont pas législatifs et je partage
totalement cet esprit c'est pour ça que
le gouvernement dès 2018 je le rappelle
c'est un discours du président que je
mentionnais dans mon introduction le
président demandait à EDF de travailler
sur le lancement d'un programme de
nouveaux nucléaires donc vous voyez ça
ne date pas de la semaine dernière ça
date d'il y a plus de 4 ans en 2019
nous signons un contrat stratégique de
flyer nucléaire qui programmait
notamment le renforcement des
compétences et le renforcement de la
sous-traitance en 2020 c'était un des
six secteurs prioritaires mis en avant
dans le cadre du plan de relance avec un
plan de montée en
investissement de 472 millions pour ces
sous-traitants de la filière nucléaire
en 2021 nous lançons France 2030 avec
1,2 milliards d'euros pour la recherche
et développement et l'innovation en plus
des montants déjà existants peut
peut-être renforcer ce programme mais en
tout état de cause il a le mérite
d'exister et d'avoir été doté
aujourd'hui il n'est pas consommé
intégralement même si tous les appels à
projets sont d'ores et déjà lancé
notamment pour accompagner de nouveaux
SMR mais aussi les enjeux de fermeture
du cycle et je rappelle qu'il y a
également 200 millions d'euros pour le
renforcement des compétences qui conduit
justement à prendre des décisions en ce
moment sur le territoire je pense
notamment à la région Normandie en 2022
nous avons engagé les débats sur le mix
énergétique et sur le nucléaire
justement pour se soucis d'acceptabilité
de démocratie nous avons nommé un délai
délégué nouveau nucléaire nous avons
nommé à nouveau président directeur
général de DF avec une mission très
claire d'excellence opérationnelle et
sur le nucléaire existant le problème
des centrales et le programme nouveau
nucléaire entre autres missions
vous nous interpellez sur le fait que le
projet de loi a été présenté dans la
précipitation je suis juste rappelé
qu'il a été déposé le 2 novembre dernier
sur le bureau du Sénat c'est-à-dire il y
a deux mois et demi le programmation il
s'agit je voudrais préciser puisque je
sens qu'il y a un doute sur le mix
énergétique nous ne faisons pas la loi
la programmation plus réelle de
l'énergie néanmoins de façon à être
accordée nos paroles avec nos actes nous
ne reviendrons pas sur la modification
qui a été apportée en commission sur le
plafond de nucléaire de manière à ce que
les choses soient très claires nous
portons un projet de relance du
nucléaire et donc nous considérons qu'il
n'est pas illégitime pour donner ce
signal à la filière de dire ce n'est pas
plafonné à 61 gigawatts de puissance
néanmoins nous porterons un amendement
qui rappelle qui va falloir diversifier
notre production électrique pour une
raison toute simple qui est mathématique
c'est que d'ici 2035 les seules
augmentations de capacité de production
nucléaire seront marginales ce sera la
connexion de Flamanville un gigawatt un
gigawatt et demi et ce sera
l'amélioration des délais de maintenance
qui font l'objet d'un audit qui est que
nous avons commandé et dont les
résultats sont actuellement mis en
application pour gagner 3 à 4 semaines
sur les arrêts de maintenance il en
résulte qu'on est dans un scénario soit
nous décidons de ne pas augmenter notre
production électrique et on restera au
niveau d'énergie nucléaire mais on sera
totalement dépendant d'autres pays dont
vous avez pour certains rappelés qui
n'étaient pas tous nos amis pour notre
approvisionnement énergétique ou alors
nous prenons en main notre nos
responsabilités ce que vous avez fait en
votant très largement le projet de loi
énergie renouvelable et mécaniquement
vous allez avoir un pourcentage
d'énergie renouvelable qui sera plus
importante qui ne naît aujourd'hui les
mathématiques sont très claires et donc
nous ne proposerons pas de pourcentage
cible parce que c'est le propos de la
programmation pluriannuelle d'énergie
mais c'est aussi une réalité physique
que la part du renouvelable dans les 15
ans qui viennent va augmenter dans notre
mix énergétique en tout cas si ce que je
nous souhaite si nous voulons vraiment
bâtir une indépendance énergétique
je voudrais juste dire un mot sur s'il y
avait une question de Madame la
signatrice madame la Présidente prima
sur les 14 réacteurs c'est ce que la
filière indique être en capacité de
construire d'ici 2050 moi je suis prête
a interrogé ce chiffre je préférerais
être en capacité d'en construire plus
mais je préfère tenir une ligne qui est
crédible par rapport à ce que me dit la
filière je rappelle également que ces 14
réacteurs sont bien compatibles avec le
scénario dit de réindustrialisation que
s'agissant du projet Astrid mais je
crois que le président le directeur de
du CEA vous l'a dit dans son audition
c'est une décision qui a été proposée
par les acteurs de la filière l'arrêt du
projet Astrid ce n'est pas comme j'ai pu
l'entendre une décision avant tout
politique c'est une décision qu'elle
correspond à une analyse de la réalité
de ce projet
la R&D je l'ai dit elle est soutenue
et puis tac tac tac monsieur le sénateur
Dantec j'entends ce que vous dites sur
et j'apprécie la composition de votre
propos mais je veux juste rappeler une
chose très basique et probablement
technocratique l'énergie nucléaire est
une énergie bas carbone qui peut être
abondante et qui aujourd'hui est
compétitive en prix et elle se trouve
que c'est 70% de notre mix énergétique
est fort heureusement sinon on serait en
grande difficulté aujourd'hui je vous
remercie
merci Madame la Ministre alors la
discussion générale est close nous
allons passer à la discussion du texte
de la commission
nous avons des articles additionnels
avec un amendement 12 le monsieur salmon
madame la Présidente
prévoit une interdiction d'exportation
de stockage de l'uranium de retraitement
à l'étranger l'exposé